BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE THREE. AS
WE HAVE HAVE IN ALL OF OUR
MEETINGS THUS FAR THIS YEAR
TODAY WE ARE HAVING AN IN PERSON
HEARING IN THE STATE CAPITAL
WE'RE IN ROOM FOR FORTY SEVEN.
OUR PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA
HOWEVER ARE GOING TO BE
APPEARING REMOTELY. THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN PERSON MAY
DO SO WHEN WE OPENED PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. AFTER THOSE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM HAVE SPOKEN WE
WILL ALLOW PHONE TESTIMONY. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN IF WE CAN GET THIS
MIKE. LOWERED JUST A LITTLE BIT
WE GOT SOME ECHO OR THE SPEAKER
WE GOT SOME ECHO IN THE ROOM-
AGAIN THE PHONE NUMBERS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR SEVEN.
THE ACCESS CODE AGAIN IS ONE
IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AND A STAFF MEMBER
WILL TRY TO ASSIST YOU. ALL
COMMENTERS WILL HAVE UP TO ONE
MINUTE TO SPEAK. WILL NOT BE
TAKING ANY VOTES TODAY. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH OUR THREE DISCUSSION
ITEMS AND WHEN WE HAVE A CORE-
IT'S A NON PRESENTATION ITEMS OR
NOT TAKING A VOTE ON THAT EITHER
SO I WILL BEGIN- WITH- THREE
DISCUSSION ITEMS AND- WILL ALLOW
OUR PANELISTS TO GIVE THEIR
TESTIMONY FIRST. THEN OPEN IT UP
TO QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AFTER THE DISCUSSION
ITEMS COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY ASK
QUESTIONS. OR OTHER COMMENTS
ABOUT ANY NON DISCUSSION ITEMS
THAT THEY WOULD LIKE TO. AND OF
COURSE WE WILL END WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT SO WE BEGIN TODAY. WITH
ISSUE NUMBER ONE AGAIN CAN IF
THERE'S A WAY WE CAN TURN DOWN
AND REDUCE THE ECHO IN THE ROOM.
FROM THE SPEAKER I FEEL LIKE I'M
AT A- CONCERT- GETTING READY FOR
THE SHOW HERE. I ONLY WISH. WE
ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE
NUMBER ONE AND TO KICK THAT OFF
WE HAVE THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE C. E. C. THROUGH BY. ARE
YOU THERE MORNING MEMBERS OF MY
COMING THROUGH OKAY. YES YOU
CERTAINLY ARE. I DON'T KNOW IF I
CAN DELIVER ON- ANYTHING CLOSE
TO A ROCK CONCERT BUT I'LL GIVE
IT A TRY YEP WE'RE TALKING WE
ALWAYS WANT TO COME RIGHT. WILL
PROVIDE LIVE THE DREAM- RIGHT-
AS YOU NOTED MY NAME IS DREW
BONE ON THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. AND I GOT A NUMBER
OF THINGS TO PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY SO I WILL SPEAK VERY
QUICKLY BUT I'LL START BY SAYING
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS IN THE CLEAN ENERGY
SECTOR AS THE L. A. REPORT NOTED
IN TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA'S
POWER BY JUST SHY OF SIXTY
PERCENT. CLEAN ENERGY AND 36% OF
THAT WAS FROM RENEWABLES IN
ADDITION THE REPORT NOTED THAT
THE ELECTRICITY SECTOR SEVERAL
YEARS AGO ACHIEVED THE SB THIRTY
TWO GOAL OF 40% GHG REDUCTIONS
AS AGAINST NINETEEN NINETY
BASELINE BY TWENTY THIRTY. WE
DID A DECADE EARLIER SEVERAL
YEARS AGO SO AGAIN GREAT
PROGRESS BUT- NORMALLY THE TASK. BEFORE US IS. S. N. FROM THE
S. B. HUNDRED. THAT WE- JUST
ABOUT THIS TIME LAST YEAR THIS
WAS A JOINT REPORT WITH SEVERAL
AGENCIES. THAT REPORT SHOWED
THAT A 100% CLEAN ENERGY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE THIS
ACHIEVABLE. THAT'S GOOD NEWS BUT
TO GET THERE ARE GONNA NEED
APPROXIMATELY TRIPLE ARE
ELECTRICITY GENERATION FROM
SOLAR AND WIND AND WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO INCREASE BATTERY STORAGE
BY MORE THAN THAT. PACKAGE
BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING THAT
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM ME AND
FROM SEVERAL OF MY COLLEAGUES IS
A TWO BILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE
ACROSS SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS. IN
THE CDC WOULD MANAGE A TOTAL OF
ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION OF
THAT. IS DESIGNED TO DO A COUPLE
THINGS THE FIRST IS K. KEEP OF A
LASER FOCUS ON RELIABILITY
THAT'S REALLY JOB ONE IS BEING
RELIABLE. SECOND SPUR INVESTMENT
AND GENERATE JOBS. THIRD WE WANT
TO LEVERAGE THE LARGE AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN THIS AREA. AND
FINALLY WE WANT TO PROMOTE
EQUITY ACROSS CALIFORNIA
COLLUDING IN TRIBAL AREAS SMALL
IN COMPARISON UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES. EACH NEXT WEEK
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
TRANSPORTATION DECARBONIZATION.
TODAY I'M GONNA TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THREE OTHER AREAS
ELECTRICITY ELECTRICITY
GENERATION CARP DECARBONISATION.
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION AND
INDUSTRIAL DECARBONISATION.
LET'S START WITH ELECTRICITY
SYSTEM THE CARD THERE ARE FOUR
TOPICS ALL PRESENT FIRST IS
LONGER RATIONS STORAGE WHERE
WE'RE SEEKING TRAINER EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO OUR CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE. UNDER HIS SWORD
WILL ENABLE US TO. KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON WHEN THE GRID GOES
DOWN FOR ONE REASON OR ANOTHER
OR WHEN PRINTABLES ARE ACTIVE
WHEN THE WIND ISN'T BLOWING THE
SUN IS SHINING. IN THEIR THREE
REAL WELL PRIMARY DRIVERS WE'VE
GOT WHEN WE WHEN WE LOOK AT LONG
DURATION STORAGE THE FIRST IS
DIVERSIFICATION AS EVERYBODY
KNOWS WE'VE ALL GOT LITHIUM ION-
BATTERIES IN OUR POCKETS AND IN
OUR HOMES IN OUR CARS AND THEY
WORK EXTREMELY WELL. THEY'RE NOT
PARTICULARLY WELL SUITED HOWEVER
LONG DURATION STORAGE YOU CAN
USE THEM BUT THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE NOT THE BEST TECHNOLOGY
SO WE WANT TO DO IS LOOK AT
OTHER CHEMICAL TECHNOLOGIES LIKE
ZINC. IRON FLOW BATTERIES WE
WANT TO LOOK AT MECHANICAL
STORAGE LIKE COMPRESSED AIR AND
FLY WHEELS AND WE WANT TO LOOK
AT THERMAL TECHNOLOGIES. SECOND
BIG PLANK FOR TO SUPPORT THIS
LAUNDRY STORAGE IS HELPING
COMMUNITIES GET THROUGH GREAT
OPTIONS AS WE'VE SEEN THE SUMMER
HEAT STORMS THAT HAVE CREATED
THE P. S. P. S. ADVANCED. AND
ARE IN THE FIRES RESULTED IN
OUTAGES MANY OF WHICH HAVE THE
SPEAK SEATED FOR HOURS AND
THAT'S KIND OF THE INDUSTRY
STANDARD FOR WERE LET HIM WORKS
THE BEST FOR OUR RANGE SO WE
WANT TO LOOK AT EIGHT HOURS AND
BEYOND AND IT EIGHT HOURS. THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE PS PS AND
THAT'S WHAT THE MITIGATED BY
HAVING THAT STORAGE IN PLACE AND
FINALLY. A GREAT SUPPORT AS THEY
SB ONE HUNDRED NOTED WE'RE GONNA
NEED LOTS OF LOTS OF STORAGE AND
INSANITY BE PLACED ON VARIOUS
PLACES THROUGHOUT THE GRID AND
SO THE INVESTMENT WE'RE
PROPOSING WOULD HELP US DEVELOP
THESE TECHNOLOGIES SO THAT WE
CAN PERFORM THAT FUNCTION. RBP
ARE BASICALLY SPELLS OUT IN
DETAIL AND OBVIOUSLY I'M A
POLICE TO TAKE QUESTIONS BUT
I'LL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ONE SO
WE CAN. WE CAN MOVE THROUGH
THESE UP QUICKLY TO THE NEXT ONE
IS GREEN HYDROGEN HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS WERE SEEKING FOR
GREEN HYDROGEN. AS I THINK YOU
ALL KNOW AND I KNOW YOU HAD A
FUEL CELL VEHICLE AT ONE POINT-
THE HYGIENIST ALREADY AVAILABLE
IN PLAYING A ROLE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SPACE IT'S ALSO A
POTENTIAL PLAYER AND HARD TO
ELECTRIFY SECTORS WERE HIGH
HEATS. ARE IMPORTANT IN IN
VARIOUS INDUSTRIAL PROF. AND
THAT'S FINE GRAYSON. IT CAN COPY
OR WITH. FOSSIL GAS. AND CAN BE
USED AS A- STORE. AND THEN AND
THEN BURN OR BRUNCH FEEL SO.
WHEN NEEDED. HOWEVER IT'S A NEW
TO THE SPACE- HYGIENE AND- WE
GOT A LOT TO LEARN. OUR STRATEGY
IS A NUMBER STRESS BECAUSE IN
ORDER TO USE HIGH JUNIOR TO
PRODUCE IT. UNLIKE WHEN WHERE
YOU CAN JUST PUT UP A IN A BILL
SOMETHING PUT IT AND GET FREE A
FREE RESOURCE. FOR SOLAR WERE
CAN USE THE IN YOUR- YOU IS
FREE- YOU'VE GOT PRODUCE
HYDROGEN AND WE- IT THE NO
REGRETS STRATEGY BECAUSE WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO PRODUCE
IT IN A GREEN WAY. OVER 95% OF
IT TODAY IS PRODUCED USING
FOSSIL FUELS AND THIS FUNDING IS
GOING TO HELP. TURN THE TIDE ON
THAT IT ALSO HELPED US ATTRACT
FEDERAL FUNDS OF THE FEDERAL
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE LAW AS
A LOT OF FUNDS AVAILABLE IN THE
THIRD AND IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
MATCHING REQUIREMENTS SO WE
THINK WE WERE. WELL POISED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT THIRD IS
AWFUL WHEN. WE'RE SEEKING FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
OFFSHORE WIND THIS IS AN
ENORMOUS UNTAPPED OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA. WHEN COMPLIMENTS
SOLAR NICELY BECAUSE. IT OFTEN
BLOWS WHEN THE SUN IS DOWN. IN
OUR S. ONE HUNDRED REPORT- I DO
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT AND IT
LOOKED AT IF WE HAVE TEN
GIGAWATTS OF OFFSHORE WIND THE
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WHAT WOULD
THAT DO AND THE ANSWERS THAT
WOULD SAVE A BILLION DOLLARS AS
AGAINST OTHER PORTFOLIOS OF
REACH OF RESOURCES. SO THIS IS A
THIS HOLDS A LOT OF PROMISE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT SPENDING
SOME OF THE FUNDS IN EARLY STAGE
ENVIRONMENTAL PLANNING AND
REVIEWS AND SOME OF IT AND
INFRASTRUCTURE OUR PORTS WHERE
FATHER MOST SUITABLE TO OFFER
WENT FORTH AND FINALLY IN THIS
FIRST ELECTRICITY-
DECARBONISATION SECTOR IS ENERGY
MODELING THIS IS A MODEST
REQUEST OF SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
BUT IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL WE
IN PUTTING TOGETHER THE SB ONE
HUNDRED REPORT WE RELIED VERY
HEAVILY ON MODELING TO LOOK AT
ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT SCENARIOS
THAT. WE COULD BE FACED WITH IN
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND WE'RE
GOING TO INVEST BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN THIS IT'S CRITICAL
THAT WE MAKE WISE DECISIONS AND
IN MODELING IS REALLY A TOOL
THAT WILL HELP US. SECOND OF ALL
THAT WAS ALL THE LITERACY
DECARBONISATION ITEMS SECOND IS
BUILDING. THE CAR WE JUST UP ONE
ITEM. THEY WANT WE'RE SEEKING
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO NO DOLLARS
FOR EQUITABLE BUILDING TO. IT
AGAIN AS YOU ALL KNOW WE'VE GOT
REALLY WELL IN CALIFORNIA WITH
OUR NEW BUILDINGS WE'VE GOT SOME
OF THE BEST MOST EFFICIENT MOST-
BUT LEAST CARBON PRODUCING
BUILDINGS IN THE ENTIRE WORLD-
IN THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
DESERVES A LOT OF CREDIT FOR
DOING THAT HOWEVER OUR EXISTING
BUILDING STOCK HALF OF WHICH WAS
BUILT BEFORE THE ENERGY
COMMISSION EXISTED IN BEFORE ANY
STANDARDS WERE IN PLACE AND
ANOTHER BIG CHUNK OF IT. IN THE
EARLY DAYS WHEN THE STANDARDS
WERE NOT LIKE THEY ARE TODAY-
THAT'S A MUCH HARDER SECTOR TO
TACKLE FOR A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT REASONS I CAN GO INTO
ABOUT I'LL SKIP OVER THAT- SO
WE'RE PROPOSING TWO THIRDS OF
THAT. FUNDING GO TO DIRECT
INSTALLS TO TARGETED TOWARDS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME FOLKS
AND THE BALLOTS ONE THIRD OR SO
FOR A REBATE PROGRAM AVAILABLE
TO EVERYONE. WE EXPECT THAT BOTH
OF THESE EFFORTS WILL JUMP START
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION IN
CALIFORNIA. FINAL ARE FINE OKAY
. IN D. KARBALA GOT TO. THE
FIRST IS WHAT WE AFTER THE FOOD
PRODUCTION INVESTMENT PROGRAM.
AND THE SECONDS MORE BROAD
INDUSTRIAL DE CAR SO ON. AN
ACTIVE THIS WAS ORIGINALLY
FUNDED WITH CLIMATE INVESTMENT
FUNDING IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. WE
RECEIVED A HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS INVESTED ALL
THAT. WE HAD TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF APPLICATIONS
MANY IF NOT MOST OF WHICH- THE
DIDN'T GET FUNDED WERE
MERITORIOUS PROJECTS BUT WE
SHOULD HAVE ENOUGH FUNDING TO
FUND THEM. SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE SHOWING 7280%
SAVINGS ON. ENERGY CONSUMPTION.
AND THE- THE CARB SCORING A
VARIOUS PROJECTS PLACED. THE F.
TYPE INVESTMENTS ON A- ON A
DOLLAR PER. METRIC TON. OF CO
TWO EQUIVALENT. VERY HIGH IT'S
GOING VERY WELL IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF THIRTY THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS PER METRIC TON. AND
WE ESTIMATE THAT THE INVESTMENTS
IN THAT PROGRAM WILL SAVE
ANOTHER FIFTY ONE MILLION. PER
YEAR ONCE EVERYTHING'S FULLY
BUILT OUT. SO THIS IS NOT A VERY
POPULAR PROGRAM WE JUST WANT TO
EXPAND THAT- AND FINALLY I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT- INDUSTRIAL THE
KERBAL SEEKING. TWO HUNDRED TEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND ESSENTIALLY
WHAT WE WANT TO DO HERE IS. TAKE
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM FF WHICH IS
VERY LABOR INTENSIVE WE WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH INDUSTRY EARLY
ON THERE WAS DEEP SKEPTICISM
ABOUT. THE ABILITY FOR THE FUNDS
TO DO ANY GOOD IN IN THE
INDUSTRY. AND I THINK IF YOU ASK
ANYONE ON THE INDUSTRY THAT SAID
THIS THIS WORKED OUT REALLY WELL
SO WE WANT TO TRY TO REPLICATE
THAT. AND THE MORE BROAD
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR WHERE WE HAVE
FORTY THOUSAND INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES IN CALIFORNIA POINT
OVER A MILLION PEOPLE. THE
DUCHESS SECTORS OF BOTH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR. OVER A THIRD OF
THE STATE'S FOSSEL GAS USING
ABOUT 20% OF OUR GHG EMISSIONS.
SO WHAT WE'D BE LOOKING AT-
SOMETHING MEMBERS IN THIS IN
THIS. CATEGORY IS. THERE IS LIKE
SOME. DEMICHELIS GLASS GHG.
WHERE THERE'S REAL AND REAL READ
TO THE SORT OF THE BASS WE THINK
WE CAN LEARN LOT FROM THE FOOD
PRODUCER PROBE. AND WE WILL DO
WORKSHOPS WITH ALL PRO TO LEARN
FROM FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
INDUSTRY FROM OTHER STAKEHOLDER
ABOUT HOW BEST TO SHAPE THEM BUT
UP THAT'S PLAN AND I THINK VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THEM WITH FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- HAVE A
REPORT FROM. I'M SORRY I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR REPORT DO
WE HAVE- ANYTHING THAT FROM-
LMAO. GOOD MORNING MR SHARON
NUMBERS ROSS BROWN WITH THE LA-
CAN YOU SEE AND HEAR ME. RIGHT.
YES OKAY GREAT- SO ABOUT OUR
OFFICE RELEASED OUR ANALYSIS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED CLEAN
ENERGY PACKAGE A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO NOW- THAT ANALYSIS IS
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE IT'S
ALSO THERE'S A LINK AVAILABLE ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE I'M
GONNA HAVE. TO GO THROUGH ALL OF
OUR COMMENTS BUT I'M NOT TRYING
TO HIGHLIGHT THE MAIN PIECES OF
OUR ANALYSIS- AND I'M GONNA
BREAK IT UP INTO TWO PARTS ONE
WILL BE JUST SOME OVER ARCHING
COMMENTS ON THE PACKAGE OF THE
WHOLE MAN RUN THROUGH SOME OF
OUR MAIN COMMENTS ON THAT KIND
OF WORK THE ARCHITECTURE OF IT
AND THEN ON AN OFFER A FEW KIND
OF SPECIFIC COMMENTS ON JUST A
FEW OF THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS SO
I'M GONNA JUMP RIGHT IN. FIRST
WE THINK THE PACKAGE BETTER
TARGETS A REASONABLE STEP BACK.
IF THE GOAL OF PROMOTING A LONG
TERM CARP. OKAY THE FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT- KEY AREAS WORSE.
SECOND PROGRESS HELP LOWER COSTS
ACHIEVING TERM GAS REDUCTION
GOALS. AND SOME OF THE OTHER
PIECES UPON FOR EXAMPLE THE
EQUITABLE BUILDING. PROGRAM
TARGETS ONE OF THE LARGEST
SOURCES OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE. THE
SECOND- OVERARCHING AS WE THINK
ALLOCATING STATE GENERAL FUND
RATHER THAN- UTILITY ELECTRIC
RATEPAYER FUNDS REALLY HAS
MERIT- FOR A LOT OF THESE
PROGRAMS. HERE THE STATE'S CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAMS HISTORICALLY
HAVE BEEN PAID FOR THROUGH
ELECTRICITY RATEPAYERS THROUGH
HIGHER ELECTRICITY RATES. EVEN
THOUGH SOME OF THE PRIMARY GOALS
OF THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS
REALLY ARE GOING TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS OF
SMOKEBENEFITS ACCRUE TO THE
BROADER PUBLIC AND SO WE THINK
THERE'S A- STRONG RATIONALE FOR
USING STATE GENERAL FUND FOR
THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE. BROAD SOCIETAL
BENEFITS. ALSO ACROSS RIDLEY
INTERVIEW PROGRAMS ARE ONE
FACTOR ONE OF MANY FACTORS BUT
ONE FACTOR THAT CONTRIBUTES TO.
CALIFORNIA'S RELATIVELY HIGH-
RETAIL ELECTRICITY RATES AND
SOME OF THE ADVERSE CONSEQUENCES
OF THOSE HIGHER ELECTRICITY
RATES ARE ONE THEY CAN
DISCOURAGE ELECTRIFICATION SO
THAT CAN BE PROBLEMATIC- IN SOME
OF THE STATE'S DECARBONIZATION
EFFORTS. ALSO ELECTRICITY RATES
ARE RELATIVELY REGRESSIVE
APPROACH TO RAISING REVENUE AND
SO WE DO KIND OF THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH OF
USING GENERAL FUND IN THIS AREA
HAS A- LOT OF MERIT. THIRD BIG
PICTURE COMMENT IS- REALLY WANT
TO BUY WITHIN THIS PROPOSAL WITH
THE LETTER SO WILL HAVE BALANCE
KIND OF LONG TERM DEBT. THE
COULD BE ACHIEVED A LOT OF THE
PROGRAM AGAINST SOME OTHER NEAR
TERM PRIORITIES THAT MIGHT. MY
GIVE ME. SO MUCH THE PROPOSED
FUNDING IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
ACTIVITIES. TO AGAIN TO ME THESE
LONG TERM THE CARD. GOALS AND-
THE PROGRAM THE G. WERE BETTER.
ARE LIKELY TO BE RELATIVELY
MODEST OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
AND SO. THE LEGISLATURE
AUTOMOTIVE TOPIC BALANCE SOME OF
THE LONGER TERM BENEFITS THAT
MIGHT BE TREATED WITH OTHER NEAR
ME. AND MEDIUM TERM PRIORITIES
IT MIGHT HAVE SO FOR EXAMPLE
OTHER PROGRAMS AIMED AT MEETING-
YOU KNOW TWENTY THIRTY- MEDIUM
TERM GREENHOUSE GAS SCHOOL SUCH
AS METHANE REDUCTION PROGRAMS
OR- OTHER ENERGY RELATED
PROGRAMS SUCH AS WITH RESILIENCE
AND RELIABILITY. OR OTHER
STATEWIDE PRIORITIES THAT MIGHT
BE KIND OF NEAR TERM PRIORITIES
THE LEGISLATURE. LEGISLATORS.
USE THE GENERAL FUND. THE
NETWORK AND FIND CAN HOLD CALL-
IS AS YOU THERE'S A AND THE
DIRECTOR MENTIONED. OTHERS A
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL OF A- FOR
SOME SIMILAR. IN THE AND PER
BILL- OKAY- CAN- MIGHT PAGE
TWENTY H. TWENTY ONE AND TWO OF
YOUR AGENDA INCLUDES A TABLE
THAT'S- PROVIDE SOME MORE
INFORMATION ON THE ON THE WIDE
VARIETY OF- FEDERAL PROGRAMS
THAT. ARE TARGETED SIMILAR THING
INCLUDING CLEAN HYDROGEN HUBS
CARBON CAPTURE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS. INDUSTRIAL MISSION
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS LONGER
ASIAN ENERGY STORAGE. BUT IN
MANY CASES THE FOR DETAILED
FEDERAL GUIDANCE ABOUT HOW THE
FUNDING CAN BE USED AND HOW IT
WILL BE ALLOCATED ISN'T YET
AVAILABLE. BUT THE RESULTS NOT
CLEAR HOW THE GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE
STRATEGICALLY TARGETS FUNDING IN
A WAY THAT BEST COMPLIMENTS ON
THE FEDERAL FUNDING. SO FOR
EXAMPLE FOR THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
USE STATE FUNDING TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL FUNDS IN A WAY. THAT
HELPS FURTHER STAPLES- PROGRAMS
SUCH AS- FUNDING TO PREVENT. AND
ENHANCED THE WORK STATE. UP AT
THE IT DOESN'T CANNELLA KATE-
FUND FOR THAT STATE NOT MOST
PROGRAMS. GOT A QUESTION OR IS
THIS ARE THERE TO GET AND BETTER
FUNDING THE STATE FUNDING. THE
HELPFULNESS OF THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANNA IN THE- TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGY FOR YOU STATE FUNDS AND
THAT THAT BEST COMPLEMENTS
FEDERAL. RESTRUCTURE PACKAGE. SO
I'M NOT. TWO- AT THE SPECIFIC
TIME ON A FEW OF SPECIFIC RECALL
ARE THROUGH TO THREE ERRORS
QUICKLY OF I CAN ONE OF THE ACT
BILL THE CAR PROGRAM- WE
RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE DIRECT
MINISTRY COOPER ADDITIONAL
DETAILS HOW THE FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS AFFECT AND KIND OF THE
OVERALL STATEWIDE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION STRATEGY- FOR
EXAMPLE WHAT'S THE ROLE OF THESE
PROGRAMS RELATIVE TO OTHER
POTENTIAL POLICY CHANGES SUCH AS
CHANGES IN ELECTRICITY RATE
STRUCTURES THAT LOWER
ELECTRICITY RATES AND COULD
ENCOURAGE A BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION. WHAT IMPACT
ELECTRIFICATION EFFORTS STOP ON
REMAINING NATURAL GAS COSTS FOR
CUSTOMERS IN PAIN FOR A KIND OF
SOME OF THOSE FIXED
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS AND THEN-
ANOTHER FINAL EXAMPLE WHY IS THE
INTERNET CONNECTION THE MOST
APPROPRIATE AGENCY TO ADMINISTER
THIS NEW DIRECT INSTALL PROGRAM
THAT'S BEING PROPOSED- AS YOU
LIKELY KNOW THAT FOR MANY
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT ALREADY OPERATES A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT WEATHER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TARGETED AT
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND FOR
THE COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT TO
EXPLORE AND WIND UP PROPOSAL IS
TO HAVE A NEW PROGRAM AT THE
ENERGY COMMISSION RATHER THAN
RELYING ON THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND IF AFTER
KIND OF THESE RESPONSES IT'S
STILL UNCLEAR WHY THE PROPOSED
APPROACH BY THE ADMINISTRATION
IS MOST COST EFFECTIVE OR
EQUITABLE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
SCALE BACK THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
ARE FOCUSED ON WAYS THAT THAT
HELPED- DIFFERENT OPTIONS AND.
DEVELOP A LONG TERM STRATEGY.
THE SECOND IT'S BECAUSE RECALL-
IS THE- PUMPS. PROJECT WHICH- I
DON'T BELIEVE DIRECTOR TOUCHED
ON BUT IS TWO HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION OF TO THE FOR A- TO KIND
OF THAT- PUMPS FACILITY OR A
BILL- IF THAT THIS PROPOSAL HAS
MAYOR OF THE WEIGHT INTEGRATE
RENEWABLE AND UNDER THE ON POWER
MAKE CERTAIN AT THE END OF HOW
PROVIDED A MORTGAGE HOUSES OF
KIND OF THE COST AFFECT OF THE-
HER DAUGHTER. SO WE RECKON
ALLEGED DIRECT MINISTRY TO
PROVIDE- THAT NOW SENT OF COST
OF FOR TO OTHER OPTIONS. STATE
ON THE PULSE OR THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDES GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PROJECT WE DO RECOMMEND THAT IT
ADOPTS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING. OR TO ESTIMATE THE
NET ANNUAL REVENUE GENERATED
FROM THE PUMP STORAGE ONCE IT'S
OPERATIONAL ENTRANCE FOR THAT
AMOUNT THE GENERAL FUND THAT'S
THE ARGUE THAT STATE TAX
TAXPAYERS ARE PROVIDING THE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROJECT TO BE
REASONABLE FOR THE STATE
TAXPAYERS AND TO KIND OF.
RECEIVE THE FINANCIAL BENEFITS
FROM THE PROJECT. AND THEN THEY
- FINAL PIECES I'D THERE'S- I
DON'T THINK ANY MINUTE WITH
ENDED UP ARE THERE'S A THE
PROPOSAL INTERVIEW. EFFORTS AT
THE W. R. IT INCLUDES THREE NINE
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND PRETTY TO
BE OUR SUPPORT ENERGY REAL.
ACTIVITIES EVER WRITTEN ENGLISH
ROGER THIS. SMALLER PIECE OF THE
- BECAUSE WE KNOW THINK IT OF
YOUR AND MINISTRATION OF
ADEQUATE DESCRIBE. HOW THE THREE
NOT DOLLAR WOULD BE IN THE NEED
FOR RESOURCE SO I'M BY WILL
MICHAEL THERE OF COURSE NOT TO
ANSWER ANY. THE THANK. THANK YOU
AND- I NICKEL TO CALL ON- A D.
W. ARE IN THE- A. R. B- EARLIER.
SINCERITY MADE THAT MISTAKE I
THINK WHAT WE'LL DO IS HANDLE
ALL THREE OF- THESE
PRESENTATIONS- SEQUENTIALLY SO
FOR A YOU HAVE QUESTIONS- OUT
NOW ON THE C. E. C.
PRESENTATION. LET'S DO THAT AND
THEN WE'LL DO THE OTHER TWO AS
WE HEAR THE- EXCUSE ME- SO. THE
REPRESENTATIVE- OKAY HON I'VE
BEEN ASKED TO HAVE CARBON D. W.
ARE PRESENT NOW SO MY PLAN JUST-
WENT OUT OF FISCAL HELLO- HERE-
NOW FROM IDW ARE- WE HAVE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CRADDICK GOT WITH US I
THINK. DON'T WORRY WILL HOLD.
THANK YOU ACCORDING TO GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS GOOD TO SEE IT
MORNING- AS NOTED IN MINUTES. AT
CLEAN ENERGY ATTACK INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION- FOR
RESTORATION OF THE PUMP STORAGE
CAPABILITY AT THE OROVILLE DAM
COMPLEX BUT THIS PROPOSAL WILL
DO IS- TURN LAKE OR A BILL INTO
A GIANT AND THAT THIRTY- WHICH
GENERATE UP TO NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE MEGAWATTS OF
RENEWABLE. ENERGY AND THIS IS-
BUT WHEN ENERGY THAT- K. OF THE
POWER CITY THIS OF SAN FRANCISCO
JUST TO GIVE A- SENSE OF SCALE-
SO WHAT PROPOSAL WOULD DO IT-
YOU- THE- SO. ENERGY THAT'S
AVAILABLE DURING THE DAY AND
ALLOW US TO PUMP WATER BACK INTO
LAKE OROVILLE AND THEN RELEASE
THAT WATER IN THE LATE EVENING
AND- OR LATE AFTERNOON AND EARLY
EVENING HOURS WHEN ENERGY IS
MOST NEEDED AND CRITICAL FOR THE
ELECTRIC GRID. SO PROVIDES- YOU
KNOW A PIECE OF THE OVERALL
STORAGE ELEMENT NEEDED FOR THE
STATE'S TRANSITION TO CLEAN
ENERGY IN ONE OF THE REAL
BENEFITS OF THIS PROJECT IS
BECAUSE IT WE HAVE THE- TESTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE THAT
ORDER FELL ON THE PROJECT USED.
OPERATED AND PUMPED STORAGE
MODE- THE INVESTMENT NEEDED TO
RESTORE- THIS- OPERATION ON THE
ORDER OF ONE FIFTH TO ONE TENTH
OF WHAT A NEW DEVELOPMENT WOULD
COST AND THEN WE'RE ALSO ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT ITS IN ABOUT HALF THE-
TIME VERSUS OF THE PROJECT. SO
THAT THAT'S AN OVERVIEW OF THE
LAKE WATER BILL ALONG AND TO
LOOK FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS AND AT THIS TIME ALL
PASS IT OVER TO MICHAEL FITS
GIVEN. WITH THE ERA RESOURCES
BOARD. IT MORNING THANKS. THANKS
FOR THE UP JUST TODAY. THE
MORNING CARE IS A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. AGAIN MY NAME IS MIKE
THAT'S GIVEN UP WITH CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES BOARD- RESEARCH
DIVISION. AND HUNDRED
FLUOROCARBONS OR AGENCIES ARE
THE FASTEST GROWING GREENHOUSE
GASES IN CALIFORNIA AND GLOBAL.
HSCS ARE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS WITH HIGH GLOBAL
WARMING POTENTIAL THOUSAND TIMES
THAT OF CARBON DIOXIDE WHICH
HAVEN'T FORTUNATE ADVERSE
CLIMATE IMPACT IN THE NEAR TERM
. ONE OF THE LARGEST USES OF
AGENCIES IN REFRIGERATION AND
AIR CONDITIONING EQUIPMENT. AND
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD
RECOGNIZED EARLY ON THE NEED TO
REGULATE THESE PROBLEMS AND MANY
OTHER STATES OF ALL OF OUR LEAD
IN ADOPTED SIMILAR RULES TO
MITIGATE THESE PROBLEMS.
JENNIFER WAS MEET THE TWENTY
THIRD OUR GUESTS AND START TO
ADDRESS HSCS UNDER CARBON
NEUTRALITY. SO THIS PROPOSAL
THIS IS ASKING FOR FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO BUILD THE
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET.
THE FIRST OF AUGUST ON
COMMERCIAL REFRIGERATION SYSTEMS
COMMONLY USED IN SUPERMARKETS
AND GROCERY STORES. ULTRALOW
GLOBAL WARMING TECHNOLOGIES
EXIST TODAY- BARBARA HIGHER
INCREMENTAL COST AND LACK OF
FAMILIARITY WITH THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE THE PRIMARY
BARRIERS TO THEIR ADOPTION. THIS
IS PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR
EXISTING STORES BECAUSE IT IS
VERY EXPENSIVE AND CHALLENGING
TO TRANSITION TO ULTRA LOW
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL SYSTEM
DUE TO INCOMPATIBILITY BETWEEN
THE WHOLE OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
THE ABSENCE OF INCENTIVE FUNDS
EXISTING STORES ARE LIKELY TO
EITHER CONTINUE TO- USE MAKING
SYSTEMS. WHAT DO A REFRIGERANT
RETROFIT TO A MID RANGE GLOBAL
WARMING POTENTIAL REFRIGERANT
RATHER STALLING. A NEW SYSTEM.
SO TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES CORP
AWARDED FIFTEEN GRANTS TO
SUPERMARKETS. STATEMENT STATE OF
THE ART I'M A FRIENDLY FOR
DURATION TECHNOLOGIES. THAT
REDUCE I MEAN IMPACT OF
CONVENTIONAL- HFC. REFRIGERANTS
BY 99% PROGRAMS TWO PER OVER.
AND HAPPY WILL WANT TO STORES
LOW IN LOW INCOME. AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER THIS REPRESENTS LESS
THAN 1% OF ALL SUPERMARKETS IN
CALIFORNIA AND FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES ARE NEEDED TO HELP
TRANSITION THOUSANDS OF EXISTING
HFC SYSTEMS IN THE STATE. AND
WILL BE CRUCIAL IN HELPING
SMALLER STORES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. UPSETS APARTMENTS
WE WOULD CONSIDER INCENTIVES FOR
OTHER COMMERCIAL REFRIGERATION
CATEGORIES AS WELL AS THEIR
CONDITION. SO THE PENDING ON THE
SELECTED THEN USES THE FUNDING
COULD REPLACE EXISTING HIGH
GLOBAL WARMING POTENTIAL
REFRIGERATION SYSTEMS ROUGHLY
FIVE HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND STORES
. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS
FUNDING IS EXPECTED TO HELP
THESE TECHNOLOGY TYPES REACH
ECONOMIES OF SCALE. WHICH MAY
LEAD TO FURTHER MARKET ADOPTION
AND THEREFORE GREATER GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS. THANK YOU AND SO
THAT WRAPS UP THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRESENTATION OF
ENERGY PACKAGE AND- WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE. THANK YOU- THANK YOU
LET ME MAKE SURE THAT- MISTER
BROWN DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING-
ADDITIONAL- TO ADD ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
. NOTHING MORE DATA STRUCTURE
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND- OTHERS
DOES THAT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS THEY LIKE THAT
AT THIS TIME. GOOD MORNING DAY
MA'AM NOT DEPARTMENT UP AND IT'S
NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS TIME BUT
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO LET ME
OPEN UP THE QUESTION- BY-
REFERRING BACK TO OUR INITIAL.
UP A PRESENTATION FROM A-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR BALL AND-
YOU'RE RIGHT SIR I DO- RETAIN AN
INTEREST IN- UGH- HYDROGEN AND
PARTICULARLY AND- THE PRODUCTION
OF GREEN HYDROGEN- OF THE A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT'S
PROPOSED. HOW MUCH- IT IS RIGHT
HERE MARK FOR- ELECTROLYZER
SYSTEM. MOVING THAT TECHNOLOGY
FORWARD. SHE'S REALLY GOOD
QUESTION THE SHORT ANSWER IS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF IT THAT'S WHERE
WE THINK AGAIN THE MOST CRITICAL
PIECES IS BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT TO
PRODUCE HYDROGEN IS THAT HAVE TO
TYPICALLY STORE IT DELIVER IT
AND THEN CONVERTED INTO ENERGY-
BACK AND ENERGY AND SO WE THINK
THAT FIRST LEG AT THERE'S NOT
BEEN A LOT OF ADVANCEMENTS IN
THIS AREA AND WE THINK WE CAN
ADVANCED THINGS QUITE A BIT. BY
BY MAKING INVESTMENTS THERE SO
SIGNIFICANT MAJORITY OF IT WOULD
ALSO BE LOOKING AT SOME OF THOSE
OTHER ASPECTS SOME OF THE
DISTRIBUTION SOME OF THE
STORAGE- WELL AS THEIR
COMPLEMENTARY AND FINALLY I
WOULD JUST SAY WE WANT TO PUT
REAL SPECIFICS TOGETHER AND
BUILD A SOLICITATION THAT WE
WOULD PUT OUT AFTER HEARING FROM
STAKEHOLDERS AND HEARING FROM
THE BEST MINDS ON HOW WE MIGHT
DO THIS THE BEST BUT THE FOCUS
WOULD CLEARLY BE AN ELECTROLYSIS
SO- I'VE I'VE READ JUST ENOUGH
ON ON THIS TOPIC TO MAKE MYSELF.
PROBABLY. REALLY DANGEROUS- BUT
IT IT DOES TO ME THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF INVESTMENT AND
ELECTROLYZER. TECHNOLOGY GOING
ON AROUND THE WORLD MOST
RECENTLY I WAS READING ABOUT-
PROJECTED INVESTMENT. TO IN
AUSTRALIA- AND THE INVESTMENT
THEIR MUCH OF WHICH WAS COMING
FROM THE- PRIVATE SECTOR WAS IN
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS- CAN YOU
COMMENT ON SORT OF WHERE WE ARE.
TECHNOLOGICALLY AS A STATE THE
COUNTRY VERSUS THE REST OF THE
WORLD AND TO- WHITE MIGHT BE
IMPORTANT FOR US TO- TAKE A
LEADERSHIP. ROLE IN MOVING THE
TECHNOLOGY FORWARD. CERTAINLY I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE STARE RELATIVE
TO OTHERS AROUND THE WORLD IN
TERMS OF HOW TO DEVELOP WE ARE
BUT THAT THE TECHNOLOGY ITSELF
IS ON REMARKABLE USING USING
ELECTRICITY TO SPLIT HYDROGEN
OUT OF EITHER. METHANE CH FOR
WATER H. TWO O. CAN BE DONE THE
CHALLENGES HOW DO YOU DO IT COST
EFFECTIVELY HOW DO YOU DO IT
USING CHEAPER RENEWABLE ENERGY
HOW DO U. FAKE HOW DO YOU CITED.
IN A WAY THAT YOU'RE PRODUCING
AT THEN AND NOT HAVING TO INCUR
LARGE COSTS TO MOVE IT TO FAR
FLUNG PLACES WHAT'S APPEALING
ABOUT IT IS IF YOU USE SOLAR IN
PARTICULAR YOU COULD SET UP-
PROPERLY SITED SOLAR FARM.
PRODUCE ELECTRICITY NECESSARY TO
SPLIT THE WATER AND- AND THEN
YOU HAVE RIGHT WHERE YOU NEED IT
THAT THE HIGHER. I THINK THERE'S
THE THING WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
REALLY. RIGHT TO BRING COSTS
DOWN. AND TO DO THAT THAT OF
COURSE INVOLVES TECHNOLOGICAL
BREAKTHROUGHS BUT IT ALSO
INVOLVES JUST BLOCKING TACKLING
OPERATIONS WE'VE SEEN THAT IN
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY WHERE. THE
TECHNOLOGY WAS ONE PIECE OF WHAT
DROVE THE COSTS DOWN BUT A LOT
OF IT HAD TO DO IT HOW DO YOU
PUT RACKING ON THAT'S THE LEAST
EXPENSIVE HOW DO YOU GET- LABOR
TO BOB. WORK NICELY WITH THE
OTHER PARTS OF THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY IS AS OF STRUCTURE IS
BEING BUILT. TO WHERE WE WANT TO
EXPLORE ALL THOSE DIFFERENT
THINGS. THANK YOU- A WITH
RESPECT TO THE- A REQUEST FOR-
RESOURCES FOR- OFFSHORE WIND-
THE AMOUNT IS FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND- I THINK THE- UGH
UGH. A DATE THAT I SAW IN THE US
STAFF REPORT WAS- JUNE OF-
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AT WHICH UP
A POINT TO THESE OF FUNDS WOULD
BE UP OF FULLY SPENT WHERE ARE
WE. TIMELINE WISE WITH RESPECT
TO DEVELOPMENT OF- OFFSHORE WIND
AND IF WE SPEND THIS MONEY- HOW
SOON DO YOU THINK WE COULD
ACTUALLY BEGIN DEPLOYING-
VISIBILITIES- IN OUR OFFSHORE
AREAS IN THE STATE AND R. THIS
IS A TECHNOLOGY THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DEPLOYED MANY PARTS OF THE
WORLD. AND ON THE EAST COAST I'M
NOT SURE WHERE ELSE IN THE
UNITED STATES- IT STRIKES ME
THAT WORLD A LITTLE BIT BEHIND-
US IN THIS DEPLOYMENT SO- IF YOU
CAN. COMMENT ON THAT I'D
APPRECIATE IT AND IF WE WANT TO
ACCELERATE THAT PROCESS WHAT
WOULD WE NEED TO DO. QUESTIONS
THE ENERGY VISIONS AND WORKING
ON OFFSHORE WIND NOW FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON DC
IS THIS REALLY SUPPORT OF IN
FACT. THE VICE ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED RECENTLY A NATIONWIDE
GOAL THIRTY GIGAWATTS BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND- COULD WE PULL IT OFF
BY TWENTY THIRTY I THINK IT'S
POSSIBLE- BUT- WE'VE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE BUREAU
OF OCEAN ENERGY MANAGEMENT
BOWMAN. AND THERE THE CHIEF
AGENCY THAT'S THAT'S INVOLVED
AND WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE- BEEN ABLE
TO OVERCOME A LOT OF THE LOT OF
THE BARRIERS WITH LOTS OF ISSUES
WHEN YOU WANT TO BUILD OFF OFF
THE COAST. WE'RE TALKING QUITE
FAR OFF THE COAST TO IN THE TWO
PRINCIPAL AREAS ARE IN THE
CENTRAL COAST AND IN THE NORTH
COAST THE CENTRAL COAST HAS
EXCELLENT ON SHORE. CAPABILITIES
TO ACCEPT POWER AND WE'LL AROUND
THE STATE NORTH COAST NOT AS NOT
AS GOOD BUT IT'S ABOUT A
RESOURCE. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
IS WE'RE LOOKING AT QUITE A
DISTANCE OFF SHORE TWENTY MILES
PLUS AND- IT'S VERY DEEP WATER
SO UNLIKE A LOT OF THE PLACES
THAT HAVE BUILT A LOT OF WIND TO
DATE. WE WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
TETHER IT TO THE TO THE BOTTOM
OF THE OCEAN QUITE ADEPT IT
WOULDN'T BE A- YOU KNOW A LARGE
SUPERSTRUCTURE MOUNTED DIRECTLY
TO THE BOTTOM OF A SEXUALLY
EXPLODING. AND IT'S DONE BEING
DONE AROUND THE WORLD IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT UNPRECEDENTED BUT IT'S
ALSO NOT COMMON SO WE'VE GOT A
LOT TO LEARN WHAT WE'RE HOPING
TO DO WITH THIS WITH THIS
FUNDING IS START TO PAVE THE
WAY. THEY HAVE YOUR QUESTION
DIRECTLY WORKING WAS INTRODUCED
TO SPEED THINGS UP. I THINK A
LOT OF THE TIMING HAS TO DO WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN ITS
PROCESS OF- THE DEADLINE LEASE
AREAS HOLDING LEASE SALES AND
THAT SORT OF THING YOU'VE
PROBABLY READ EITHER OCCURRING
ON THE- EAST COAST. AND. WE'RE
EAGER TO SEE THE MOVE. AS WELL.
THANK YOU AND HAVE MY FIVE CALL-
IS- ON THE TOPIC OF BUILDING GOT
DECARBONISATION- THE L. A. OAK-
OBSERVES THAT- MORE DETAILS- IS
NECESSARY ASSUME. THAT WILL BE
WEEKS BUT- THE L. A. O. ALSO-
ASKS THE QUESTIONS A LITTLE BIT
IN YOUR FACE SO I APOLOGIZE FOR
THAT BUT- IT'S WHY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION- SENSORS OTHER
DEPARTMENTS THAT. I HISTORICALLY
HAVE DONE PROJECTS LIKE THIS
WIOQ- SHIFT SOME OF THESE
RESPONSIBILITIES. TO THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. PERFECTLY LEGIT
QUESTION WE- WE TALKED TO THE
OTHER. POSSIBLE ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA CHIEF AMONG THEM ONE
ONE THAT ROSS SPELLED OUT WHICH
IS SIXTY THE COMMUNITY. SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT- DEPARTMENT AND-
ESSENTIALLY WE ALL AGREED WE
CAME TO AN AGREEMENT INTERNALLY
THAT ENERGY COMMISSION WAS THE
MOST SENSIBLE PLACE TO DO THIS
WE MANAGED OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF OUR MONEY.
BACK IN YOUR DAYS AND THERE ARE
SOME SMALL ONES FUNDS COMING
CALIFORNIA'S WAY FROM THE FROM
THE FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IN THAT
AREA. AND WE'VE GOT LOTS OF
EXPERIENCE WITH ENERGY ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROBABLY NOBODY KNOWS
MORE ABOUT IT IN THE STATE THAN
THAN THAT THAN THAN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. WE ALSO- WE ALSO
MOVEMENT A LOT OF MONEY AND-
WEEK YOU LEARN THINGS WHEN YOU
DO THAT ABOUT HOW TO AVOID
MISTAKES AND- THAT'S IT THANKS I
THINK WE'RE WELL EQUIPPED TO DO
IT. AND FINALLY I'D SAY IT'S
GOING TO BE. SOMEWHAT
COMPLICATED THE CST PROGRAMS
TEND TO BE VERY TARGETED TOWARDS
WEATHERIZATION TYPE THINGS LIKE
INSULATION BETTER WINDOWS- OTHER
BETTER ENVELOPE TYPE MEASURES
WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING AT SOME
COMPLICATED ONES LIKE ELECTRIC.
APPLIANCES ELECTRIC HOT WATER
HEATERS ELECTRIC- SPACE HEATERS
AND COOLERS AND- THE TECHNOLOGY
BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG TIME BUT
DEPENDING ON YOUR FACILITY YOU
MIGHT NEED A PANEL UPGRADE
BECAUSE YOU'RE DRUNK MORE
ELECTRICITY THAN YOUR HOME OR
BUSINESS WAS DESIGNED TO.
THERE'S A LOT OF COMPLICATING
FACTORS AND THAT'S WHY WE THINK
WE'D WOULD BE WELL SUITED AS A
AS THE STATE ENTITY THAT TO
MANAGE THIS BY THE WAY WE'RE
GONNA WILL PLANNING TO HIRE OUT.
TO HAVE BEEN ADMINISTRATOR DO
THE ACTUAL INTERFACE WITH THE
WITH THE ULTIMATE FOLKS WOULD
GET THE MONEY BUT. WE WOULD WE
WOULD MANAGE THE ENTERPRISE. SO
ON THE QUESTION A- SO ARE THIS
IS. A STAFF REAL- WITH OTHER-
AGENCIES HELLO FOLKS KNOW TO- I
COME TO YOU IF THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN THESE PROJECTS.
WE'RE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH CST
CST DOES HAVE A LOT OF ACTUAL
RELATIONSHIPS THAT THEY BUILT
THEIR AIR DISTRICTS IN THE STATE
THAT HAVE DONE SO AS WELL BUT I
DON'T THINK- THIS IS A
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF MONEY AND WE
WILL DO A LOT OF WORKSHOPS AND I
AND I DON'T THINK. GETTING THE
WORD OUT TO BE OUR BIGGEST
CHALLENGE AND OF FINALLY- IF
THE- THIS IS APPROVED AND- IN
THE IN THE BUDGET WHEN WOULD WE
EXPECT UP ACTUAL PROJECTS ONE
WITH A CONSUMER ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO- REACH OUT AND- BEGIN A
PROJECT AT TO. A HIS OR HER
WHOLE. REALLY MADE A REALLY-
PORTANTINO INTO SOME OF THE
THINGS IN THE PACKAGE THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO YOU THIS MORNING
OUR LONGER TERM MODERATION
STORAGES IS SOMETHING WE'RE
GONNA BUILD AND HAVE UP AND
RUNNING NEXT YEAR- BUT BUT THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE. I'D BE HESITANT
TO GIVE YOU A PRECISE TIME FRAME
BUT IF APPROVED IN JUNE WE WERE
IMMEDIATELY GO OUT DO WORKSHOPS
AND IT YOU KNOW IT DEPENDS
SOMETIMES YOU LEARN IN A
WORKSHOP THAT SOMETHING YOU HAD
IN MIND REALLY DOESN'T WORK AS
WELL AS YOU THOUGHT AND YOU NEED
TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT AND RETOOL
SO- BUT ASSUMING THINGS WENT
WELL WE COULD HAVE- BOB
GUIDELINES IN PLACE. CERTAINLY
WITHIN A YEAR AND THEN BE ABLE
TO START PUTTIN SOLICITATIONS
ON THE STREET NOT NOT LONG
THEREAFTER SIDE I'D BE THINKING
OF SUMMER SUMMER NEXT YEAR WOULD
BE PRETTY AMBITIOUS BUT THAT
WOULD BE A REASONABLE TARGET.
ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU- LET'S
PAUSE- ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
THEN WILL PROCEED WITH
QUESTIONING CUT. FROM OTHER
MEMBERS. BLOOM HERE SENATE HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE MULLIN PATTERSON
RIVAS SMITH HERE TAKING THEIR
AND I'D LIKE TO WELCOME CHAIR
TEND TO OUR HEARING AND TO SEE
IF HE HAS ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- JUST QUICK
QUESTIONS TO OUR ACCOUNT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- ARMY WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S- AMBITIOUS PACKAGE ON
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION IT
SEEMS THAT ONE. AREA REALLY
WASN'T TOUCHED ON WHICH IS.
MOVING TOWARD- COMPLETELY
EXTRICATION FOR BUILDINGS I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS OR COMMENTS AS TO. HEAR
WHAT ROLE THEY ENERGY COMMISSION
WANTS TO PLAY ON THAT ISSUE I
KNOW THE CPUC BROTHERS A BIGGER
ROLE TO PLAY BUT JUST CURIOUS
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS ARE.
CERTAINLY WE ADOPTED STANDARDS-
THAT STANDARDS WANT TO AFFECT
LAST YEAR BUILDING STANDARDS
THAT WE ADOPT ON A ON A ROUGHLY
THREE YEAR CYCLE AND- WE WERE WE
FOR THE FIRST TIME REQUIRED THAT
ALL NEW COMMERCIAL STRUCTURE-
STRUCTURES WITH WITHIN A CERTAIN
RANGE. B. THEY HAVE SOARED ON
THEM WHICH MATCHED OUR- EARLIER
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT TAKE PLACE
ON RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS SO THAT
WAS ONE BIG YOU KNOW DOWN
PAYMENT ON ELECTRIFICATION AND
DECARBONISATION OF BUILDINGS. WE
ALSO REQUIRE THAT THE BUILDINGS
BE BE READY TO BE ELECTRIFIED
SUB SO THERE'S NOT AN APP
THERE'S NOT A MANDATE THAT ALL
NEW BUILDINGS GOING FORWARD MUST
BE. ZERO EMISSION OR MUST BE
ENTIRELY ELECTRIC BUT WE'RE
WE'RE PAVING THE WAY AND A LOT
OF- PROGRESSIVE BUILDERS ARE
GOING TO FLORIDA MAKING
BUILDINGS ALL AFTER PARTICULARLY
IN THE IN THE PRESIDENTIAL SPACE
SO WE'RE EAGER TO. SEE THAT
HAPPEN AND THERE WERE MANY WHO
FELT LIKE WE SHOULD HAVE PUSHED
IN OUR LAST BUILDING CODE CYCLE
TO MANDATE BOB WELL EDUCATION
AND WE- MY BOSSES THE
COMMISSIONS THAT CHOSE NOT TO DO
THAT AT THIS TIME BUT- I THINK
WE'RE REALLY WELL ON THE WAY. TO
THAT. TO THAT OUTCOME. THANK THE
WINDS WIND THE NEXT TIME YOUR
RIVAS THOSE I GUESS. I FORGET
THE LOS LIKE PAYING THE GOLDEN.
ITS MARKETS CAN'T GO BRIDGE YOU
KNOW YOU'VE YOU'RE DONE. BY WHEN
YOU'RE DONE AND YOU TELL FOR
MINUTES AND YOU START SO WE'VE
WE'VE WE'VE BEEN WORKING HEAVILY
ALREADY ON THE NEXT CYCLE THE
LAST CYCLE WE REFER TO AS OUR
TWENTY NINETEEN STANDARDS. AND
WE'RE LOOKING WE'RE CALLING
THESE THE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
STANDARDS SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
ADOPTING IN IN CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY TO THE NEXT THE
NEXT ROUND OF STANDARDS THAT
THEY GET THEY GET EVER TIGHTER-
IN TERMS OF REDUCING ENERGY
CONSUMPTION GREAT AND I MAY
NEVER REALLY URGE ALL THE ALL
THE COMMISSIONS TO REALLY TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT. DOING A MANDATE IT
DOESN'T REALLY SEEM TO MAKE
SENSE AS WERE PUTTING UP- NEW
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS WHETHER
WE'RE- BUT DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO
BUILD NATURAL GAS PIPELINES INTO
THOSE- NEW COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS
DOESN'T REALLY MAKE SENSE TO.
LOOK AT- NEW BUILDINGS AND TRY
TO HAVE THEM FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT THEY SHOULD BE ALL ELECTRIC
OR NOT I THINK THAT. THE STATE
NEEDS TO TAKE A MUCH STRONGER
ROLE IN PROVIDING THAT DIRECTION
TOWARD A LECTURE FOR CATION-
BECAUSE I THINK IF THEY DON'T DO
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A HODGE PODGE
OF STANDARDS AND THEN WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA END UP DOING IS-
IT'LL BE EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
TRANSITION IF YOU ACTUALLY PUT
UP NEW BUILDINGS. WITH NATURAL
GAS THAT GOES INTO RUSSIA
BROTHER WE HAVE ALL THE
TECHNOLOGY WE NEED. IT'S VERY
SIMPLE TO MOVE FORWARD- WE COULD
EVEN DO OF MORE WATER
RECAPTURING IS SO JUST SEEMS
THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO- SET A
CLEAR DIRECTION ABOUT WHERE WE'D
LIKE TO GO RATHER THAN JUST
LEAVING IT UP TO INDIVIDUAL.
BUILDING DEVELOPERS AND BUILDING
OWNERS AS TO AS TO WHERE THEY
SHOULD GO BECAUSE- WE'RE CLEARLY
NOT GOING TO MAKE OUR YOU KNOW
I'M OUR GOALS IF WE CONTINUE TO-
SEND MIXED SIGNALS READ
REGARDING OUR GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS- REGARDING ALL OF
PARIS CLIMATE GOALS I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT- AND SO. ON
WHEN DO YOU THINK YOU'LL BE SO
WITH THAT THE TWENTY. TO
ADOPTION WOULD YOU THINK THOSE
WILL BE ADOPTED OR CONSIDERED.
BOB WHAT THE HOPE IS THAT THEY
THAT THEY GET ADOPTED AND INTEL
ENCOUNTER YOUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND THEN THERE'S A LAG BUT AS TO
WHEN THEY BECOME EFFECTIVE WHICH
TYPICALLY ABOUT A YEAR A YEAR
AFTER THAT TO GIVE THE INDUSTRY
AN OPPORTUNTY TO ADJUST. AND
WHAT WE WHAT WE DO IN OUR
STANDARDS AS WE PROVIDE MULTIPLE
PATHWAYS TO COMPLIANCE IN THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY'S. BETTER
ENGAGED IN AND DEVELOPING LIKE
THIS BECAUSE THERE'S A
PRESCRIPTIVE PATH WE BASICALLY
PROVIDE A LISTING IF YOU CHECK
ALL THESE BOXES. YOU SATISFY THE
STANDARDS MORE. MORE PLAYERS
LIKE TO USE- A DIFFERENT
APPROACH WHERE YOU CAN TRADE AND
- ON WHAT CLIMATE ZONE YOU'RE IN
OR WHAT BUILDING MATERIALS RE
AVAILABLE OR WHAT STYLE BUILDING
YOU DO. YOU MIGHT FIND AS A
BUILDER ONE. APPROACH TO MEETING
THE STANDARDS OF MORE APPEALING
THAN ANOTHER AND YOU'RE FREE TO
DO THAT AS FAR AS RATCHETING
DOWN TO MANDATING. ALL LIKE
CREEK THAT'S A THAT'S I MEAN IN
TERMS OF THE ENERGY COMMISSION
DURING THAT THAT REALLY REMAINS
TO BE SEEN AND CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATURE- CAN HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AS WELL. NO PRE
APPRECIATE THAT MCGETTIGAN YEAH
I THINK- ENERGY COMMISSION TOOK
A HUGE LEADERSHIP ROLE AND-
ASKING THAT ALL NEW RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS YOU JUST HIS HIDE YOU
KNOW. CITED THIS AROUND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS HAVEN'T.
ROOFTOP SOLAR SO THAT WASN'T
THERE THERE ARE DIFFERENT PASS
ON THAT SO I DON'T THINK THERE
SHOULD REALLY BE. A DIFFERENT
PATH. FOR CATIA IS VERY CLEAR-
THE SCIENCE IS VERY CLEAR THIS
IS THE DIRECTION. THAT WE NEED
TO GO ESPECIALLY AS WE ALECTRA
FIRE OUR ENTIRE- GREETED IN OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. SO
THAT IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO
HAVE A GROUP FULL OF CLEAN
ENERGY IN FOR A BUILDING NOT TO
BE USING THAT CLEAN ELECTRIC
GRID SO- I GET AGAIN- YOU KNOW
I'LL BE TALKING DIRECTLY TO THE
COMMISSIONERS. WELL AND REALLY
URGING THEM TO REBOUND CONSIDER
THIS AS A AS A NEW FORD AND-
DELIBERATE THAT TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BUILDING BECAUSE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE. YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS
THANK YOU. CLICK HERE FOR A
MAJOR WANT RESPONSE TO THE
FUNDING WERE SEEKING FOR
BUILDING- BUILDING THE CARPET
IS. WILL WILL WILL. WE THINK
WORK HAND IN GLOVE WITH WHAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED- ELECTRIC
TECHNOLOGIES TO POWER HOMES AND
BUSINESSES. IT'S UNREMARKABLE.
IT'S ALSO RELATIVELY UNCOMMON IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S QUITE POPULAR IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE. OR THE
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD. BUT BY. BY
PRIMING THE PUMP AND PUTTING
SOME FUNDS OUT THERE INTO OUR
OUR PARTICULAR LOW INCOME AREAS.
IT'LL GIVE THE WHOLE BUILDING
INDUSTRY AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET A
LOT MORE FAMILIAR WITH WITH HEAT
PUMPS AND I'VE GOT A GUN TO MAKE
MY HOUSE. ONE ONE STEP TRIED
NEARLY ALL LIKE TRICKS I LEARNED
THERE'S A THERE'S SOME NEW
THINGS IN THE CONTRACTORS. HAVE
YOU KNOW SOME OF OUR PART NOW
MORE OR LESS ABOUT. ABOUT THESE
THINGS I THINK GETTING GETTING
THOSE FUNDS OUT THERE AND
GETTING THESE THINGS. MORE
NORMAL IN CALIFORNIA. WILL HELP
FACILITATE WE ARE DESCRIBING.
YEAH CAN COULDN'T COME AGREE
MORE SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR OF YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THAT.
THANK YOU. AB DE AS I CALL ON
MISTER SMITH LET ME- JUST SAY
IT'S NOT EVERYONE WHO WOULD
CHOOSE TO ATTEND A BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE THREE HEARING. ON
THEIR BIRTHDAY SO. HOW WE WANT
TO WISH MEDIA HAPPY BIRTHDAY
THANK YOU OF MISTER BLOOM.
QUESTION IS THE LAST REPORT I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO FIND IN TWO
THOUSAND- NINETEEN. CALIFORNIA'S
NET ELECTRICITY IMPORTS WE'RE A
LITTLE OVER SEVENTY MILLION
MEGAWATT HOURS. WHICH WAS 25% OF
THE STATE'S SUPPLY. WHAT IS IT
NOW OR DO WE HAVE ANY UPDATED
<c.red>NFORMATION THE TWENTY TWENTY</c>
ONE. RESCUE ME UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT QUESTION I DON'T THINK
IT'S THAT HIGH I THINK IT'S-
WILL LOWER THE 25% BUT WE CAN
GET YOU THOSE PRECISE NUMBERS
OKAY IT WAS THAT HIGH IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING
TO FIND OUT IF WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO BRING THAT DOWN. WORKS WITH
THE PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEN- I HAVE OTHER OMV IT'LL
COME BACK ON HERE. NUMBER NUMBER
THERE ARE COLLEAGUES FROM THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION WHO-
MAYBE JUMP AND TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT IMPORTS. WHY
DON'T IS THAT ALRIGHT YEAH YEAH
I WAS OPENING MY WE HAVE THEM
ANSWER THAT. I SERVICES HI
THERE- IT'S CALL OUT WITH THAT
ENERGY DIVISION YOU SEE I
ACTUALLY ALSO DO NOT HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS AT MY FINGERTIPS AND
WHATNOT- INCLUDE THE- PUBLIC
UTILITIES- WHAT I DID SO I THINK
WE CAN WORK TOGETHER WITH BACK.
COULD YOU SEE TO GET CURRENT
NUMBERS FOR THAT. IN FUNDING FOR
THE GET OROVILLE DAM STILL
RECYCLE THE WATER BACK UP TO
THE- POWER PLANT I CURRENTLY
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
WATER. IN ORVILLE LAKE RIGHT NOW
TO EVEN GET INDIA ELECTORS
ELECTRICITY THROUGH THE
HYDROELECTRIC PLANT. I KNOW THE
FUNDING- GOING TO THE FUTURE FOR
IT AND WE MIGHT HAVE WATER TO
FUTURE WHAT WE'RE PRODUCING ZERO
ELECTRICITY AT OUT OF OR BILL. A
HYDROELECTRIC DAM CURRENTLY.
YEAH GOOD MORNING MEMBER THIS IS
THAT. TED CRADDOCK. RIGHT NOW
THEY WERE A BILL WE THE WATER
LEVEL IS HIGH ENOUGH WHERE WE
PRESUME THAT POWER OPERATIONS
OUT OF THE LAKE- THAT HAPPENED.
IN THE DECEMBER TIME FRAME SO WE
DID HAVE A BRIEF PERIOD BECAUSE
OF THE EXTREME DROUGHT. I
WOULDN'T LAKE FELL BELOW- THE
POWER PLAN ELEVATION BUT WE'RE
BACK IN OPPOSITION NOW. IN I
KNOW WE ALL WANT TO GO
ELECTRICITY BUT CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA STILL. CONSUMING ONE
POINT MILLION BARRELS OF CRUDE
OIL EVERY DAY. WE'RE IMPORTING
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION BARRELS A
DAY FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES THEN
I'LL GO AHEAD AND RUSSIA. THE
RAINFOREST. IS BEING DESTROYED
IN THIS WORLD WE'RE TRYING TO.
SAVE THE WORLD IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WHY ARE WE NOT APPROVING
PERMITS TO DRILL OIL IN
CALIFORNIA SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
IMPORTED OIL. THE SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. THEIR
SCIENTIFIC STUDY. THAT IS THE
THOSE OF SUPERTANKERS IS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER ONE POLLUTED IN
THE LA BASIN. SO I DON'T KNOW
WHERE IT'S GONNA GO BUT I DO
BELIEVE WE CAN'T JUST TURN THE
SWITCH ON TO ELECTRICITY WE
STILL NEED TO PRODUCE OIL. AND
SLOWLY GO TO ELECTRICITY YOU'RE
CUTTING OUT AN INDUSTRY WE'RE
STILL IMPORTING THAT OIL STILL
AFFECTING THE AIR STILL
AFFECTING THE RESIDENTS AND I
THINK WE NEED TO DRILL OIL IN
CALIFORNIA EXPRESSLY RIGHT NOW
IN THE TIME OF THE WORLD. WE
NEED TO BE TRY TO BE SELF
SUFFICIENT HERE WITHOUT
IMPORTING. FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
LABOR STANDARDS DO NOT HAVE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS WE MIGHT
BE FIXING IT IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
THE AIR FROM THE REST OF THE
WORLD STILL CYCLES OF THE EARTH
. THAT'LL BE MY COMMENT. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH A CHERRY BLOOM- MY FIRST
QUESTION IT JUST DEALS WITH OUR
PROCEDURES AND STUFF BUT-
DIRECTOR BOTTOM HAS BEEN VERY
EASY FOR ME TO HEAR- BUT SOME OF
THE OTHER PRESS PRESENTERS IT
REALLY DIFFICULT- AND I WOULD
HOPE I'VE BEEN AT SOME OTHER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS WHERE THEY'VE
NOW BEGUN. BACK TO IN PERSON
PRESENTATIONS AND SO I JUST
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT IF WE
CAN I WOULD SURE APPRECIATE.
HAVING THEM HERE AND NOT MISS.
THE KEY WORDS IN AN AND ALL OF
THAT BUT THIS TECHNOLOGY IS- IS
JUST NOT GOOD ENOUGH FOR US TO
BE ABLE TO RIGHT I THINK HERE
ARE SOME OF THE IMPORTANT THINGS
ARE PRESENT RIGHT- THANK YOU I
THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE HAVING.
TROUBLE HEARING- SOMETIMES WE
CAN MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
ACCOUNT THAT ARE HELPFUL I KNOW
THE FIRST DOES BECAUSE A LITTLE
BIT MUFFLED TO. GREAT THANK YOU-
AT SIX THE SECONDLY- FOR
DIRECTOR BOTTOM- AND THAT- I
REALLY APPLAUD THE-
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO- TRY
TO MOVE US TOWARDS GREEN
HYDROGEN THE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- THAT A STATE IS FUNDED
THERE- I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL. FOR US TO GET A NEW A
NEW ENERGY SOURCE OF FOR GOING
TO DO IT ON A ON A MASSIVE SCALE
FOR US TO MOVE AS QUICKLY TO THE
GREEN. HYDROGEN AS POSSIBLE- SO
THAT- WE GET THOSE BENEFITS AND
WE DON'T SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND
ENERGY ON SOMETHING INTERMITTENT
THAT- CHEWS UP RESOURCES- I
WOULD LIKE TO. POINT OUT THAT
THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT AS YOU
ARE TRYING TO WORK ON THE
TECHNOLOGY AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GERMAN
BREWMASTER. I THINK THE MOST
APPROPRIATE QUESTION WHAT
PERCENTAGE IS GOING TO BE ON
ELECTROLYSIS- AND- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE WERE FOCUSED ON THAT.
AND YOU POINTED OUT THAT TRYING
TO GET IT WHERE. IT COULD BE
PRODUCED AT. LIKE AT A SOLAR
FARM- SO IT WOULD BE RIGHT THERE
IN TERMS OF LOCATION BUT
HYDROGEN DOES HAVE THE-
POTENTIAL TO BE MOVED AROUND BY
HYDROGEN TRUCKS- AND HYDROGEN
TRUCKS. HAULING HYDROGEN TO
OTHER PLACES COULD BE A VERY LOW
CARBON ORDERS HAVE APPROACH ALL
THE WAY AROUND- ENJOY JUST ASK
US TO IT WHILE YOU ARE LOOKING
AT. THE SYNERGIES. OF OKAY I
REGION AT THE SOLE OUR FARM SIDE
OF IT- OTHER OP. FOR THE PURGE
PRODUCTION OF ELECT- FOR THE
GREEN HYDROGEN- SEEM TO ME TO BE
APPROPRIATE ALSO- MY- NEXT
COMMENT- IS- THE LONG MIGHT NEXT
QUESTION IS FOR THE LONG TERM
STORAGE- OPTION. I NOTED IN THE
PRESENTATION BY THE L. A. O.
HYDROGEN IS NOT LISTED AND COULD
YOU ANSWER FOR ME- DIRECTOR
BOND. IS HYDROGEN. A CONCERT
GOER GOING TO BE CONSIDERED ONE
OF THOSE NEW TECHNOLOGIES THAT
WE WOULD BE CONSTRUED LOOKING
OUT FOR LONG TERM STORAGE.
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY AND WE'RE
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT IT AS A
PIECE OF THE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT'S DEDICATED CHIEFLY TO
ISSUE COULD YOU NOTED- ARE
PROPOSALS TO CHEAPLY DEDICATE
THAT TOWARD ELECTROLYSIS BUT WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT OTHER PARTS
OF THE CHAIN INCLUDING INCLUDING
STORAGE- I THINK YOU'RE PROBABLY
REFERRING MORE TO THE GRID SCALE
STORAGE- VERSUS TANKS AND THAT
SORT OF THING FOR MORE READY USE
BUT BUT WE THINK WE NEED TO LOOK
AT ALL THOSE PIECES IN THE
INDUSTRY SPOKE ABOUT HYDROGEN SO
THE NUMBER THAT YOU'VE GIVEN THE
FLAG A WHOLE BUNCH OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE JUST NEED TO GET. A LOT
MORE KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT YOU CAN
DEFINITELY TRY CUT AGAIN BUT
WHEN YOU COMPRESS IT YOU YOU
BURN A LOT OF ENERGY COMPRESSING
IF YOU LOOK A FIGHT YOU BRING
EVEN MORE ENERGY SO THERE'S
COSTS AND BENEFITS OF THE ALL
THE MULTIPLE APPROACHES AND WE
NEED TO LEARN A LOT MORE ABOUT
THEIR PHYSICALLY THE SIX COULD
BE LOCATED IN WHAT THE TRADE
OFFS ARE. WELL I AT. I
APPRECIATE THAT IT AYE AYE SIR
SHARE. CHAIR BLOOM- INTO IN THE
HYDE. AND THE COMMENTS AND AN
INTERESTED- THAT HE'S
DEMONSTRATED AND THEN CERTAINLY
SUPPORT THAT- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT. IF I COULD GO TO
THE PORCH- AND- EIGHT A QUESTION
THAT I HAVE- WITH THE IF WINCH.
THE OFFSHORE WIND. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY OF THESE BIG WIND
TURBINES THE CLOSER WE DO IT TO
THE SHIP THAT IS ACTUALLY GOING
TO TAKE THEM OUT. BETTER OFF
WE'RE GOING TO BE- IS THERE ANY
ATTENTION YET BEING PAID TO. HOW
WE MIGHT LOCATE THE ASSEMBLY OF
THESE BIG WIND TURBINES- THAT
NEAR THE PORCH- SO THAT- WE-
DON'T HAVE THE AWKWARDNESS OF
TRYING TO TRANSPORT TO A BIG
WIND TURBINES- FROM THE ASSEMBLY
POINT- TO THOSE PORTS. ANY ANY-
IT EXPLORATION OF THAT YET.
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S PART OF WHAT
WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT I THINK
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE RIGHT ON
THAT THESE ARE LARGE THE YOU
KNOW WE'RE LOOKING AT HUNDREDS
OF THE LONG TURBINES TODAY AND
THEY'RE GETTING LONGER EVERY DAY
IN THE MEGAWATTS PER. TURBINE IS
GOING UP EVERY DAY AND SO WE'RE
IN THE PERFECT SPOT TO IT TO
ADAPT TO THAT BUT BUT MOVING
THOSE THINGS EVEN FROM SOME OF
THE PARTY CALIFORNIA TO THE
COAST IS NO TRIVIAL MATTER SO.
ABSOLUTELY LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF ONSITE PRODUCTION
TO LOAD RIGHT ONTO A SHIP TO
TAKE THEM OUT TO SEA IS THIS
SOMETHING WE WANT TO LOOK AT
CLOSELY. GREAT THANK YOU AND MY
QUESTION IS- PROBABLY FOR D. W.
R. HERE REGARDING THE PUMP
STORAGE AT- ORVILLE- STE. I'M
CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF- OF ALL
OF THE- CARBON NEUTRAL
APPROACHES THAT WE CAN WE CAN
COME UP WITH- MY QUESTION FOR-
D. W. OURS. DO YOU HAVE DATA ON
THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY OF PUMPED
STORAGE. VERSUS YOU TALKED ABOUT
USING THE EXCESS SOLAR ENERGY
FOR PUMPED STORAGE- AND HOW DOES
THAT COMPARE TO USING THAT
EXCESS SOLAR ENERGY FOR SOME
OTHER- SOME OTHER ENERGY
PRODUCING- CAPABILITY BECAUSE AS
WE- HAVE HAD THE QUESTION- FROM
MISTER. SMITH I'M SORRY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGREED THAT- ALL ALL
CORRECTOR BUT- AS WE HAD A
QUESTION ABOUT- THE NEW NORMAL
WE HAVE IN TERMS OF WATER
SUPPLY. WE MAY NOT HAVE ENOUGH
WATER. TO BE ABLE TO
CONSISTENTLY USE THAT SO IS THIS
GOING TO BE THE BEST INVESTMENT
OF THAT SOLAR ENERGY- IS MY
QUESTION- WHEN WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY HAVE ENOUGH
WATER TO PRODUCE ELECTRICITY. SO
DO YOU HAVE DATA ON HOW
EFFICIENT THAT IS VERSES- THE
OTHER POTENTIAL USES OF THAT
SOLAR ENERGY THAT EXCESS SOLAR
ENERGY. FOR TO PRODUCE OTHER
RENEWABLE ENERGIES. FOUR YEAH
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
MEMBER IT'S MAYBE TWO PIECES TO
THAT ONE AS A RELATED TO THE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY. OF THE SYSTEM
SO I'M STORAGE- IS GENERALLY A
CLOSED SYSTEM WHERE YOU HAVE TO
WATER BODIES THAT YOU'RE
TRANSFERRING. WATER TO AND FROM
IN THE CASE OF A QUORUM BELL
WILL ALSO HAVE- NO FLOW THAT
COMES INTO THE LAKE AND PASSES
OUT OF THE LAKE- SO IT'S A
COMBINATION OF PROCS- BUT BUT
GENERALLY THE LAKE YOU KNOW
UNDER. MOST OPERATIONS SCENARIOS
HAS THE CAPABILITY TO. TO
OPERATE A HIGH IN IN THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT THE HYDROLOGY- WE SEE
IN THE STATE. AT THIS YEAR WAS
AN EXAMPLE THOUGH WERE YOU KNOW
UNDER AN EXTREME DROUGHT
CONDITIONS- THERE COULD BE NO
SOME TOP GAMES WHEN- WATER
AVAILABILITY BECOMES A FACTOR-
THE OTHER PART OF THE QUESTION
IS RELATED TO THE EFFICIENCY OF
THE OF THE- UPON STORAGE VERSUS
OTHER TYPE ENERGY STORAGE. I
THINK ONE OF THE BENEFITS OF
PUMPED STORAGE IS. THAT HE-
HYDROPOWER URBAN'S GENERATING
EFFICIENCY AT LAKE OR A BILL IS
ON THE ORDER OF NINETY FIVE
PERCENT. AND THEN ARE PUMPING
EFFICIENCY BACK INTO THE LAKE IS
ON THE ORDER OF 8290% SO THE
OVERALL ENERGY EFFICIENCY OF
STORING- SOLAR ENERGY. AS YOU
KNOW IN THE LAKE OR BILL'S THE
BATTERY IS PRETTY HIGH- IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER TECHNOLOGY.
SO THE CHORE AS MY AND MY
CORRECT SUGGEST THAT IF YOU USE
A- A HUNDRED MAKE UP A HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF ENERGY- PRODUCE
ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE- WITH THE
SYSTEM. THAT YOU HAVE ABOUT A
15% DROP OFFICE IS THAT CORRECT. WITH WITH THE HYDRO. THAT'S A
VERY. FAIRLY GOOD AS- GEN- I CAN
AT. IT YES. ANSWER TWO YEARS-
AFTER THIS- HEARING IF THAT'S IN
AND YOU MAY THIS YEAR THERE'S
NOT ENOUGH WILL. YOU KNOW WE
TALK ABOUT THE NEW NORMAL IN
ADDITION BEING A DROUGHT THERE
RATHER IN A- OF VERY ASIAN. AND
SO THE NEW NORM MAY BE WHAT WE
ARE EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW. DO
WE HAVE IT HAVE THERE BEEN ANY
OTHER YEARS AND IN THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS WHEN ORVILLE WAS
TOO LOW TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
ELECTRICITY IT AT ANY TIME. THIS
THE FIRST TIME IN THE HISTORY OF
THE PROJECT- IN SO THAT THE DROP
BELOW THE PLANTS. IN LATE AUGUST
AND THEN WE ARE ABLE TO RESUME
OPERATION IN DECEMBER. GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
IT- I BELIEVE THAT- AND THAT
THAT'S IT FOR MY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
SEEING NONE- THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW
TO ISSUE. TO WHICH IS- THE-
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC GRID
EMERGENCY GENERATOR SUPPORT. AND
I BELIEVE WE HAVE- MISTER
LEDESMA PRESENTING ON THAT. YES
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SO DETAIL
REGARDS EFFORTS AND ENERGY
RELIABILITY I'LL BE READING OFF
MY NOTES ON THAT CALL- BE ABLE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. EFFORTS ARE
TO SUPPORT THAT GRID RELIABILITY
CALLED BY CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
RESULTING INCREASES IN WILDFIRE
HEAT WAVES AND DROUGHT
CONDITIONS. I TO MITIGATE THESE
DISRUPTIONS GOVERNOR SIGNED AN
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION ON JULY
TWENTIETH. JULY THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE RAFTING OF THE
URGENCY PROCLAMATION WITH
FABULOUS THEY STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR THE CDC LICENSE.
HOWARD HONORS OF TEN MEGAWATTS
OR MORE THAT WOULD DELIVER NET
PEAK ENERGY BEFORE OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ON SEPTEMBER EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE CDC GRANTED A
LICENSE FOR TWO TEMPORARY POWER
GENERATORS AT THE DECOMMISSIONED
GREENLEAF ONE. COGENERATION
FACILITY AND YUBA CITY. AND TWO
AND A LICENSE FOR TWO TEMPORARY
POWER GENERATORS AT ROSEHILL
ENERGY PARK IN ROSEVILLE. EACH
J. L. M. TO FIVE ON PORTAL UNIT
GENERATOR GENERATE UP TO THIRTY
MEGAWATTS AND ARE AVAILABLE FOR
DEPLOYMENT DURING A GREAT
EMERGENCY DUE TO A SUDDEN ENERGY
SHORTAGE RESULTING FROM EXTREME
HEAT WAVES WILDFIRES OUR- AS
DESIGNATED AND DIRECTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ISO. DWF DATA WE ARE
DEPLOYED THESE FOR A TEMPORARY
GENERATORS LAST LAST FALL. AND
IS GOOD AT AND THE CC LICENSES
WERE FOR FIVE YEARS. ELIGIBILITY
FOR RENEWAL IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. WE ARE ALSO ENTERED
INTO SIGNED AGREEMENTS WITH BOTH
SIDES THROUGH DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. OR APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED TWENTY MEGAWATTS WHICH
COULD POWER APPROXIMATELY ABOUT
A HUNDRED THOUSAND HOMES. SINCE
THESE GENERATORS- WERE
COMMISSIONED UNDER A DEAL WE
ORDER LAST FALL HE DOUBLED OUR
CONTINUES ITS WORK TO COMPLY
WITH LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS WHICH
IS PLASTER COUNTY AND FEATHER
RIVER. TO CONTINUE THE- THE
CONSTRUCTION- INSTALLING
SELECTIVE CATALYTIC REDUCTION
SCR SYSTEMS AND MISSION CONTROLS
THAT WILL BE COMPLETED BY THIS
SUMMER. AND THAT IS THAT IS TO
BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE CC
LICENSE TERMS. AND BENITA- FORTY
IS A CONSTRUCTOR MINUTES BY THE
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND ALSO WE
WOULD NEED TO BE COMPLIANT TO
ALL ELECTRIC MARC STANDARDS. THE
FUNDING THAT- IN THE BILL WOULD
SUPPORT THE OPERATIONAL COSTS
FOR THE GENERATORS AS FOLLOWS.
SO THAT IT WILL ALLOW THE TO WE
ARE TO MAINTAIN STAFF EXPERTISE
AND SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS TO
OVERSEE THE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OF ALL THE UNITS AND
BALANCE OF PLANT FACILITIES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LICENSE
PERMITS. REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS
SUCH AS NEWARK RELIABILITY
STANDARDS AND SERVING SURE THE
READINESS TO OPERATE UNDER THE
KALISTO DIRECTIVE. IN SUPPORT OF
THE GRID RELIABILITY. AND WITH
THAT I'LL- I'D LIKE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU- MISTER BROWN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE THE L. L. A-
REPORT. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES
TO RAISE WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BUDGET REQUEST HI HALF THANK YOU
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
ASSUME YOU HAVE. NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. THE MORNING CARE
WRINKLED BARN FINDS CORRECT IN
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BUT YOU'RE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WILL WANT A QUESTION
THAT'S RAISED IS- THAT- THE- THE
DEPLOYMENT OF AT LEAST ONE OF
THESE GENERATORS- WAS IN A
COMMUNITY WITH SIGNIFICANT AIR
QUALITY ISSUES ALREADY- IS THERE
SOMEWHERE ELSE WERE- THEY COULD
HAVE BEEN LOCATED. YEAH HI THIS
IS A JEWEL AND AS MILLION SO
WHEN THE- EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION
WAS DECLARED AND D. W. R. I
COLLABORATED WITH THE CDC AND
THE CAROLINAS SO TO IDENTIFY ALL
POTENTIAL SITES AROUND THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT WENT THROUGH
A- TWO TIERED APPROACH TO LOOK
FOR THE YOU KNOW MOST SUITABLE
SITE AND- ENVIRONMENTAL
SENSITIVITY AREAS WERE TAKEN
INTO- INTO ACCOUNT
UNFORTUNATELY. YOU KNOW THERE'S
NOT A THEY WERE NOT A LOT OF
SITES THAT WERE READILY
AVAILABLE TO BE- CONSTRAINED
AIRED AND YELL THE PROCUREMENTS
AND CONSTRUCTED BY THE FALL. AND
SO THE LIST REALLY DWINDLED DOWN
TO ABOUT FORTY SITES THAT. WE
WERE WE REALLY PASSED THE FIRST
LEVEL OF TEAR SCREENING WHEN WE
GOT TO THE SECOND TIER SCREENING
WHICH REALLY THEN LOOK THAT. AS
WELL AS ALL THE EQUIPMENT TO
READ TO INTERCONNECT TO THE GRID
TRANSFORMERS INTERCONNECTED
BILITY IS THERE ANY NATURAL GAS-
TO PASSAGE IF THERE ARE- YOU
KNOW WATER FOR THE TURBINES.
WHEN REALLY IN THAT NARROW THAT
DOWN ONLY TWO SITES. REALLY MET
THE CRITERIA TO BE ABLE TO YOU
KNOW- CONSTRUCT THESE GENERATORS
AND SO ROSALYN YUBA CITY. WERE
THE. ONLY TWO SITES THAT MET THE
CRITERIA. THANK YOU I WATER THE
PLANTS- FOR THESE GENERATORS AT
THE END OF- OF THE CONTRACT- IS
THE DEPARTMENT- GOING TO EXTEND
THE CONTRACT SELL THE GENERATORS
WHAT'S THE- IS THERE A IS THERE
A PLAN FOR. WHAT HAPPENS. YOU
KNOW THERE'S NO DIRECT PLAN FOR
THESE GENERATORS THIS FUNDING IS
JUST OPERATED MAINTAINED AND I'D
IMAGINE THAT THIS SUMMER. YOU
KNOW THE WORKING WITH THE CDC
AND THE CAROLINAS SO WE'LL BE
WORKING WITH THEM TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THERE'S A NEED TO. YOU
KNOW THAT WHAT THE WHAT THE NEXT
STEPS ARE FOR THE GENERATORS TO
SUPPORT GRID. RELIABILITY. THANK
YOU- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. MISTER. TEN THANK
YOU- JUST JUST CURIOUS WHY YOU
SETTLED ON NATURAL GAS VERSUS
LOOKING AT OTHER- ENERGY SOURCES
ESPECIALLY AS THE CHAIR HAD
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEING ONE OF
THE MOST POLLUTED AREAS OF THE
STATE AND OBVIOUSLY PROBABLY
FURTHER EXACERBATE THAT. YOU
KNOW WHEN THE TEAM OF THE W. ARE
IN C. C. IN THE COLLEGE SO
LOOKED AT YOU KNOW HOW WHAT WAS
THE FASTEST WAY TO GET EMERGENCY
GENERATORS ONLINE PORTABLE
GENERATORS WERE. REALLY THE ONLY
OPTION AVAILABLE AND REALLY
NATURAL GAS AND- DIESEL WERE THE
TWO FEELS THAT THESE PORTABLE
GENERATORS RUNS FROM OF. COURSE
WE OPTED IN. THE STATE OPTED FOR
NATURAL GAS. THE CALLOUS- ALSO
LOOK THAT. IF NO OTHER PROJECTS
THAT WERE ALREADY IN THE QUEUE
FOR BATTERY STORAGE OR ANY
OTHER. CLEANER TECHNOLOGIES BUT
NONE OF THEM COULD BE EXPEDITED
TO GET ONLINE- BY THAT FALL SO
THE DECISION WAS THAT THIS WAS
THE CLEANEST- FORM OF POWER WE
COULD GET. UNDER THE EMERGENCY
CONDITIONS WHAT WAS AVAILABLE.
GOT A TO JUST SO WE UNDERSTAND
JUST THE DIFFERENCE IN TIME
FRAME WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU SAY-
THE TIME FRAME WOULD HAVE BEEN
IF WE DECIDE TO GO WITH BATTERY
STORAGE. YEAH I CAN'T REALLY
EXPRESS AND PROBABLY MORE OF A-
TO EASIER CALLOUS SO QUESTION
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES REALLY
MANAGING THE QUEUE. I'M NOT SURE
WE CAN GET THAT INFORMATION FOR
YOU OKAY WHAT WE HAVE CC HERE SO
C. C. CAN YOU ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. THE AVERAGE MODESTO
HERE IT. CAN YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION. YEAH THE QUESTION TO
THE QUESTION WAS- MISTER LEDESMA
TALKED ABOUT HOW. AFTER
EVALUATING A VARIETY OF ENERGY
CHOICES THAT THAT NATURAL GAS
PORTABLE GENERATORS WAS
CONSIDERED THE- THE FASTEST AND
THE QUICKEST- BETWEEN THAT IN
DIESEL I GUESS THAT THE CHOICE
WAS. MADE BETWEEN NATURAL GAS
AND DIESEL MY QUESTION WAS. HOW
BIG A TIME DIFFERENCE WOULD HAVE
BEEN IF WE HAD GONE WITH. A
CLEANER ENERGY LIKE BATTERIES
LIKE SOLAR BATTERY STORAGE. HEY
THIS IS FOR THIS IS THE LEAST I
COULD HEAR THEM FROM THE
ASSESSMENTS DIVISION- I AM
HOPING THAT- WE HAVE. SOMEONE
FROM OUR CITING DIVISION ON TO
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION BURKE
LET ME SEE IF I CAN GET AN
ANSWER FOR THAT- AND IF WE CAN
CONTINUE THE QUESTIONING AND- I
WILL CHIME IN. THAT THAT THAT'S
GREATER THAN I GUESS THIS IS
JUST A FOLLOW UP AS WELL WHEN IT
HONESTLY WHEN WIND WAS WHAT DID
YOU FIRST START LOOKING AT-
THESE RESOURCES- YES. WELL THE-
WAS MADE JULY THIRTIETH SO. YOU
KNOW EARLY AUGUST AND MAYBE IN
THE DAYS AFTER THAT IS WHEN THE
DEPARTMENT. AND IT'S EASY IN THE
CAROLINAS SO STARTED LOOKING
FOR. SITES THAT COULD BE A- THE
BILL SOME STARTED USING EARLY
AUGUST- TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
CORRECT OKAY AND ART ARE
DEADLINE WAS- AS THE ORDER SAID
WHEN THEY NEEDED TO BE
OPERATIONAL PRIOR TO OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST SO FROM A
CONSTRUCTIVE BILITY. THAT IS
REALLY FAST TIME FRAME BLESS YOU
. AND THESE GENERATORS WERE
ACTUALLY STEPPED UP AND-
COMMISSIONED IN FIFTY ONE DAYS
WHICH IS. IN MY IN MY OPINION-
RECORD TIME YEAH NOT NOT FLAT
AFTER A BRIGHT FREESHEET THE
EFFORTS TO WIN TO REALLY GET
THESE- TURK TURBINES I THINK THE
QUESTION IS THAT. FROM YOU KNOW
WE HAVE WE HAVE A STATE GOAL TO
GO TOWARD A 100% RENEWABLE
ENERGY STATE GOAL TO BE- MOVING
TOWARD CLEAN CLEAN ENERGY SO IT
JUST SEEMS THAT THE AGENCIES
THAT ARE REALLY IN CHARGE OF
CREATING THE LEADERSHIP- TOWARDS
THAT GOAL- SOMEHOW. YOU KNOW IT
IGNORED IT AND DECIDED TO GO
WITH A- DIRTIER SOURCE AT A TIME
WHEN THESE COMMUNITIES OBVIOUSLY
NEED THE ENERGY BUT ALSO AT A
TIME WHEN THE THESE COMMUNITIES
NEED IN ADDITIONAL MEDICATIONS
SO THEY SEEM TO BE ON THE FORTY
EIGHT THE AGENCIES WERE TRUSTING
TO CLEAN. THE AIR AND CLEAN THE
ENERGY- SEEM TO IGNORE IT WHEN
IT WAS CONVENIENT UNFORTUNATELY
. SEARCH TO DO WE HAVE OF. THE
PROPER CC PERSONAL. I KNOW
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR- SEAN PETARD
. AS MR PETARD AVAILABLE.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS DAMON NOT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT SEAN IS ON THE LINE-
BUT WE WILL WORK WITH ENERGY
COMMISSION COLLEAGUES TO GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT ANSWER.
THANK YOU KNOW LIKE THIS IS
BECAUSE FROM THE PC I CAN'T
ANSWER SPECIFICALLY TO THIS
EFFORT BUT ANECDOTALLY. IN THE-
PC DIRECTED UTILITY- THE I USED
TO. DO AS MUCH PROCUREMENT UNDER
ARMOR AGENCY PROCUREMENT-
PROCEEDINGS AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
SAME PERIOD OF TIME STARTING
QUITE A BIT EARLIER. AND THEY
ARE THEY WERE REALLY. THEY WERE
DOING THEIR LEVEL IDEA. ANY
STATESIDE BATTERIES WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AND DEPLOYED ON A FAST
TURNAROUND. I DON'T THINK IT AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO SO- BUT
WITH A LOT MORE LEAD TIME AND I
DON'T THINK THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN. THAT YOU KNOW POSSIBLE
THEY WOULD OF A POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO TURN THAT REQUEST AROUND
IN TWO MONTHS AND- AT THAT POINT
IN TIME BY JULY- EITHER YOU ARE
WITH THE COMPETING. WITH.
PROJECTS ALREADY BEING- PLACE
THE ELUSIVE THE SAME TIME SO I
CAN JUST SAY. I'M TRY TO I DON'T
BELIEVE. I FROM PERSPECTIVE THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET
BETTER. ADDITIONAL BATTERIES
WHAT WE ARE ALREADY DEPLOYING.
ARE LOCATED AND PUT IT SERVICE
WITHIN A MONTH OR TWO AT THAT
POINT IT'S- GONNA THANK YOU
SUGGEST BUT JUST GO BACK TO THE
QC. BUT IT IS CLEAR THAT THE
PROCUREMENT DIRECTIVE IS TO
PRIORITIZE CLEAN ENERGY. OVER
DIRTY ENERGY IS THAT CORRECT.
YES WE YOU KNOW WE APPLIED A
SORT OF LOADING ORDER. TO THE
DIRECTION WE GAVE WITHIN THE-
EMERGENCY PROCUREMENT PROCEEDING
TO GO AFTER. YOU KNOW BATTERIES-
DEMAND SIDE RESOURCES LIKE
DEMAND RESPONSE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND- A- VARIETY OF
OTHER RESOURCES AND THAT AND
THEN. YOU KNOW IT EFFICIENCY
IMPROVEMENTS AT AT POWER PLANTS
THAT WOULD ACTUALLY PRODUCE. THE
SAME OR MORE POWER FOR. MORE
POWER FOR THIS THE SAME OR LESS
THAT. INCREMENTAL ENERGY SO
THAT'S GOT THE APPROACH WE TOOK.
PERFECT SO IT'S NOT THINKING
I ADD A LITTLE MORE INFORMATION
BECAUSE THE STATE I THINK DID
TAKE A VERY PROACTIVE APPROACH.
THESE GENERATORS PORTABLE
GENERATORS TYPICALLY DO NOT HAVE
S. C. OURS. TO EAT YOU KNOW THEY
ARE VERY CLEAN GENERATORS THE
STATE INVESTED IN S. C. A. R.'S.
WHICH IS AN UNTYPICAL FOR
PORTABLE GENERATORS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE USING THE BEST. OF
THE BEST TECHNOLOGY FOR A
MISSION CONTROLS AND THEN SECOND
THESE GENERATORS WILL ONLY BE
OPERATED UNDER. CAROLINE STILL
EMERGED- EMERGENCY- ORDERS SO
THEY WILL NOT BE BUILT INTO THE
MARKET SO THEY WILL NOT BE
RUNNING AS A MARKET YOU KNOW IS
A TYPICAL. OF A GHASTLY
GENERATOR SO WILL ONLY BE USED
FOR GOES. UP EXTREME CASES
RUBBER BULLET AND I SHOULD
ACTUALLY. ACTUALLY NUMBER. THE
LIST OF HEARING SO. OKAY
QUESTION SO YOU'RE $
BUT THERE ARE GOING TO BE. USED
OUR MERGE SORT WHICH GENERAL
WILL BE DOOR WILD FOR SEASON
WHEN THE AIR THE MOST POLLUTED
SO YOU'RE GOING TO BE USING A
DIRTY ENERGY SOURCE TO FURTHER
POLLUTE THE AIR DURING WILDFIRE
SEASON. AND YOU'VE BEEN COMING
TO COME TO THIS COMMITTEE YOU'RE
ASKING FOR THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND YOU HAVEN'T
DEMONSTRATED- EXACTLY WHAT THE
PC JUST SAID. WHICH IS THAT YOU
NEEDED TO PRIORITIZE CLEAN
ENERGY SOURCES FIRST. IN NOBODY
HERE. CAN TELL US WHY YOU'RE
PROCURING DIRTY ENERGY TO BE
USED DURING WILDFIRE SEASON TO
FURTHER POLLUTE THE AIR WHEN
THERE'S ALREADY POLLUTED. SO I'M
NOT I'M I'M JUST HAVING A HARD
TIME UNDERSTANDING WHY NOBODY
HERE. IS ABLE TO ANSWER THE MOST
SIMPLE QUESTION AS TO WHY WE
DIDN'T USE A RENEWABLE SOURCE.
DRIVE OVER PART OF FINANCE I
THINK I JUST GRABBED ELABORATE
WHEN MR THAT THAT MEANT THAT.
WHEN TO BE PROCURED WHICH IS
UNDER LAST YEAR'S ENERGY- AND
EMERGENCY THERE WAS A TIME FRAME
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO STAND THEM
UP IN ORDER TO HAVE THEM
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS POTENTIAL-
KIND OF ENERGY SHORTFALLS- AND
SO. IN THAT TIME FRAME THERE WAS
AN ALPHA CONDUCTED AND B. WERE.
AVAILABLE OPTION TO CONSTRUCT
AND GET THEM IN PLACE HI. IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO BE HYPED
DURING THAT TIME I APPRECIATE
THAT THERE WAS ANALYSIS
CONDUCTED. HOW COME NOBODY IS
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE.
PRESENTING THE ANALYSIS THAT.
WHO WHO DID THIS ANALYSIS WORTH. AND ALSO MYERS AT AND LOOK AT
MY AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
YOU HAD SINCE AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY NINE AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
SO IT'S FOURTEEN MONTHS NOT TWO
MONTHS. SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW CAN YOU COME TO THE
COMMITTEE. YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ANALYSIS THAT YOU SAID WAS
CONDUCTED THE PERSON WHO
CONDUCTED THE ANALYSIS IS NOT
HERE. AND IN YOUR IN YOUR
COMMENT TO THIS COMMITTEE IN
ASKING FOR MONEY. YEAH SO WE
COULD DEFINITELY CERTAINLY
FOLLOW UP WITH THE QUESTION YOU
HAD ON HOW MUCH LONGER IT WOULD
HAVE TAKEN- TO GENERATE BE OR TO
PUT IN PLACE THE OTHER. HAVE A
CLEANER ENERGY OUT THERE WE
DON'T HAVE THAT WRITTEN IN
TODAY'S BILL BECAUSE THAT BUT WE
DEFINITELY DID TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION. BUT WILL
DEFINITELY GET THAT RESPONSE
BACK YOU UP AGAIN THIS REALLY
WAS JUST. INTENDED TO BE COVERED
AT THE CONTINUE THE GREENBERG AT
THE OTHER PEOPLE KNOW WHICH LAST
YEAR- ENERGY EXECUTIVE ORDER.
ACKNOWLEDGE THE POTENTIAL AIR
QUALITY CONCERNS THAT WERE
CAUGHT. AND ACTUALLY DIRECTED B.
THE AIRPORT THEN ALSO LOOK AT
WAYS TO MITIGATE EQUALITY IMPACT
ASSOCIATED WITH LAST YEAR THE
CONTROL- EMPLOYEE IMPACT LOCALLY
WE DID NOT NEED TO YOUR
GENERATOR LAST YEAR. WELL THERE
WERE NOT ANY KIND OF ADDITIONAL
EMISSIONS PRODUCED LAST YEAR.
AND THIS YEAR IN ORDER O
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
AND IT'S RIDDLED WITH THE
VIOLATED. WHICH WE ARE INVESTING
AT THE AT THE ARE YOU KIND OF
MAGICAL. TO BE ABLE TO THE- ANY
POTENTIAL KIND OF AIR QUALITY
AND BACK. WHEN WE BROUGHT INTO.
AND BE RESTORATION. PLAN IS WHY
LAST YEAR WE DID HAVE. THAT KIND
OF CONTINGENT- IF THERE ARE
MISSION- INCREASES. THAN WHAT
ABOUT HELP ALL IN THE COMMUNITY
AND LIKELY TO HAPPEN- BUT THEN
MOVING FORWARD FOR THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS WHILE WE DETERMINE
MORE LOCKER READY. LEAVE AIR
MISSION BECAUSE THEM WORK. THAT
WE GOT MY POURED YOUR- OR ACTION
FROM LEGISLATURE. BADMINTON TO
CUT. BE THERE QUALITY IMPACT
WHAT I DID WE RUN IT BETTER IF
GETS VERY WHAT.
I STILL DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU
COULD DO AN ANALYSIS THAT
SOMEHOW YOU DON'T WANT TO SHARE
WITH US AND COMMITTEE ONE SO YOU
WANT TO GET BACK TO US LATER. SO
I REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
BE MUCH BETTER PREPARED WHEN YOU
COME THROUGH THIS. THROUGH ALL
THE DIFFERENT COMMITTEES IT
SEEMS THAT. EVERY TIME A MAN
COMMITTEE PEOPLE CAN'T AFTER THE
MOST SIMPLE BASIC QUESTIONS IN
THE REFER TO THINGS THAT THEY
DON'T REALLY HAVE- I DON'T
REALLY. HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PRESENT SO EITHER YOU NEED TO
REALLY RETHINK WHO'S PRESENTING
FOR ANY COMMITTEE. OR YOU NEED
TO BE MUCH BETTER PREPARE.
SO WE HAVE A- QUESTION- THAT IS
STILL UNANSWERED- I'M GONNA ASK-
THE AGENCY- TO LET US KNOW WHEN
. THAT INFORMATION WILL BE OF IT
MADE AVAILABLE TO US. AND THAT
WOULD BE A WHEN I SAY TO US I
MEAN ON LOG OF COMPACTED. OF
JUST GIVE ME A MOMENT. WE GET AN
ANSWER TO MY QUESTION. THERE'S A
SOME KIND OF KIND OF SORT OF
ANALYSIS OR REPORT OUT THERE
THAT- YOU REFER TO. WHEN WE'LL
BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
TO THE CHAIR AND TO THE
COMMITTEE. OF THE. THE DIABETIC
TIME FRAME WILL WORK INTERNALLY
WITH OUR ENERGY COMMISSION- CAL
I FEEL CORNERED EITHER OF YOUR
HELP- CAN REVIEW THAT USUALLY
LAST NUMBER AND BE ABLE TO WRITE
IT ALL OUT HOW MUCH TIME DO YOU
NEED I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GOING
TO WORK WITH EVERYBODY TO ANSWER
MY QUESTION I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY WE CAN'T GIVE A TIME FRAME
NOW ABOUT HOW MUCH TIME DO YOU
NEED TO GIVE US A TIME FRAME
WITHIN WHICH YOU'LL PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION. WE COULD GIVE YOU A
TIME FRAME- LATER THIS WEEK AND
FROM THE WAY WE COULD PROVIDE IT
BECAUSE OF THE WEATHER YOU CAN
PROVIDE IT I. DON'T WANT TO
COMMIT CONNECT THE WE HAD TO GO
BACK AND- EARLY DEATH. WHAT IS
AROUND THE VEHICLE NOW- BUT YEAH
WE COULD FOLLOW UP WITH THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE GET FROM THE-
A TIME FRAME TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION. I THINK- MISTER
SMITH AND MR PATTERSON- EACH ONE
OF US THE QUESTION. WITH A-FOLLOW UP. WITH QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. YOU HAVE THE REPORT
RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
REPORT BY THIS AFTERNOON.
SOMEBODY'S GOT TO PUSH A BUTTON
ON THE COMPUTER WE SHOULD HAVE
THAT REPORT RIGHT NOW. UNLESS
YOU'RE GOING TO GO IN THERE AND
ADDED TO THIS REPORT. THE MAKES
YOU LOOK BETTER AGAIN. BUT I'LL
LEAVE THAT OUT WELL I WON'T
LEAVE IT ALONE I'M A GO AFTER
SOME MORE OPPORTUNITIES HERE.
YOU COME HERE AND ASK FOR THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS. BUT YOU'VE
ALREADY SPENT A HUNDRED SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THROUGH D. R. E.
A- TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR J. L.
B. E. AND THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN EARLY ACTION. SB ONE FIFTEEN.
LAST YEAR. IT'S A PRIME EXAMPLE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO BE WATCHING.
AS GOVERNMENT RUNS AMOK. ONE
AGENCY ISN'T WORKING WITH THE
OTHER AGENCY. AND WE'RE- WE ARE
GOING AFTER EACH OTHER IN THE
TAXPAYERS ARE PAYING FOR THAT.
THIS EMERGENCY WAS NOT ON FOR
SEEN OR HEARD OF SUDDEN. IN THE
GOVERNOR. IN HIS ADMINISTRATION
SEEING THIS COMING ANY ANYBODY
IN THE REPUBLICAN SEE THIS. THE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANTS THE BEEN
CLOSED DOWN. SANTA NO FREE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE DIABLO CANYON IS
LOOKING THE TWO TWENTY AT TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. HYDROELECTRIC POWER
THE BILL DEMOLITION OF THE
LAMBETH RIVER DAM. AND FIT IN
THE FAILURE TO BUILD SIGNIFICANT
NEW HYBRID ELECTRIC POWER PLANTS
SURE WE CAN SAY IT'S GLOBAL
WARMING RAINS NOT COMING WE'RE
NOT STORING WATER CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE'RE TEARING DOWN DAMS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN PLACE TO PRODUCE
CLEAN ENERGY IN THIS STATE AND I
CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHY ONE
GOVERNMENT AGENCY CAN'T WORK
WITH ANOTHER ANOTHER IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BEING FORTHRIGHT
WITH THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
. WHY COULDN'T THIS MONEY BE
SPENT A LONG TIME AGO NOT IN AN
EMERGENCY. FOR THE OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY OF BIOMASS POWER PLANTS
IN MORE HYDRO ELECTRICITY IN THE
STATE. MAYBE YOU CAN GET BACK
WITH SOME ANSWERS ON THAT FOR ME
SO I WOULD KNOW WHAT GOVERNMENT
AGENCY ISN'T TALKING TO EACH
OTHER OR WORKING WEEKLY WITH
EACH OTHER. AND THAT'S THE
PUBLIC'S MONEY THAT YOU ARE
PRETTY MUCH WASTED BECAUSE WE
CREATE. AN EMERGENCY. WHEN WE
DON'T NEED TO HAVE AN EMERGENCY
IN THE STATE. MISTER PATTERSON.
I'M MEMBERS I'VE SPENT NINE
YEARS- GOING ON TEN YEARS AS
THE- VICE CHAIR OF UTILITY. AND
ENERGY. BOB I THINK WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE PREDICAMENT THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS IN
RIGHT NOW. AND THE PREDICAMENT
IS THAT. WE HAVE ESSENTIALLY.
DETERMINED THAT THERE ARE
IMMORAL ELECTRONS AND MORAL
ELECTRONS. AND WE'RE MAKING A
VERY VERY DIFFERENT DIFFICULT TO
USE THE IMMORAL ELECTRONS.
NATURAL GAS IT'S AFTER. AND YET
IT IS THOSE VERY IMMORAL
ELECTRONS THAT ARE KEEPING OUR
LIGHTS ON. WE HAVE HAD IN THESE.
EMERGENCY CIRCUMSTANCES WE HAVE
HAD BECAUSE THE WIND DOESN'T
ALWAYS BLOW THE SUN DOESN'T
ALWAYS SHINE. ACKERLEY AT TIMES
WHEN WE NEED A RELIABLE ENERGY
WE GET- INTERMITTENT ENERGY. AND
THERE ARE IN FACT ELECTRONS THAT
WE HAVE DETERMINED TO BE A MORAL
. THEY'RE QUITE FRANKLY TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON. AND SO I THINK
IT'S RATHER DISINGENUOUS FOR US
TO. JOINT FINGERS AT THE
ADMINISTRATION OR AT THE THESE
PEOPLE HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE IN FRONT OF THEM.
INCREASING DEMAND AT A TIME WHEN
WE ARE DECOMMISSIONING
SIGNIFICANT ENERGY AT TIMES WHEN
WE NEEDED. AND WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE TODAY. WE ARE
INCREASINGLY SEEING AN
UNRELIABLE GRID. AND WE ARE SO
INCREASINGLY SAYING A HUGE SPIKE
IN THE COST OF ELECTRICITY TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT.
AND I THINK THAT- IT IT IS A-
RELATIVELY FOOLISH AARON I TO
TRY TO LEGISLATE THAT YOU KNOW
BUT AGAINST THE PHYSICS OF THE
MOVEMENT OF ELECTRONS. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT WE KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON BY USING THESE NATURAL
GAS PLANTS BY IMPORTING
ELECTRICITY ACROSS OTHER STATE
LINES AT THE TIMES THAT. WE
NEEDED. SO ON THE ONE HAND WE
HAVE THIS- NO NOTION OF- THAT
PERFECT IN MORAL ELECTRICITY.
WHAT IMPACT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE SUFFERING RIGHT
NOW THROUGH THE LACK OF THE KIND
OF ELECTRICITY THAT WE HAVE
BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO. I THINK
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO BE ABLE
TO GO TO THE- POWER GRID. TURN
THE LIGHTS ON AND AGAIN TO THE
ELECTRICITY AND FIND IT
AVAILABLE AND AFFORDABLE. AND
YET IN MY DISTRICT. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ADVERTISING THAT
IN ORDER TO SAVE CALIFORNIA AND
KEEP IT GREEN. THAT WE HAVE TO
DECIDE NOT TO USE OUR
ELECTRICITY BETWEEN FOUR O'CLOCK
AND NINE O'CLOCK. PM TO REALIZE
WHAT KIND OF. CHALLENGE THAT
PRESENTS TO PEOPLE WHO LIVE
NORMAL ORDINARY NINE TO FIVE
LIVES. WE HAVE A WE HAVE A WE'VE
AGREED THAT WE'RE BASICALLY
SAYING ISN'T AVAILABLE OR
USEABLE. BUT BECAUSE THE
ELECTRICITY ISN'T AVAILABLE
THERE. AND SO THE OVER RELIANCE
ON THE- MORAL ELECTRONS AND THE
SHEDDING OF THESE IMMORAL
ELECTRONS. HAVE CREATED A
CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH IN MY
DISTRICT RIGHT NOW. PEOPLE ARE
RECEIVING FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLAR PG&E BILLS. I MY DISTRICT
IS BEING- INUNDATED WITH PEOPLE
WHO ARE CALLING MY OFFICE AND
SAID WHAT THE HECK IS GOING ON
HERE. SO I JUST WANT TO RAISE.
THE OBVIOUS HERE. THAT IF WE ARE
SO. INTENT ON STRIPPING
CALIFORNIA FROM THESE IMMORAL
ELECTRONS. WE HAVE A CONSEQUENCE
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CREATING REAL
DIFFICULTIES FOR THE BACK VERY
PEOPLE WE SAY WE CARE ABOUT. AB
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC- WE HAVE
SOMETHING LIKE IT I THINK IT WAS
LIKE EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND.
ELECTRICITY ACCOUNTS- THAT WERE
TERMINATED BECAUSE PEOPLE
COULDN'T PAY THEIR BILLS THAT'S
NOT EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS LIKE EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACCOUNTS THERE MIGHT BE
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX PEOPLE. WE
ARE CREATING ELECTRICITY
SCARCITY. AND WE ARE CREATING
ELECTRICITY THAT IS INCREASINGLY
UNRELIABLE AND WE ARE ASKING OUR
CONSTITUENTS BETWEEN FOUR
O'CLOCK AND NINE O'CLOCK TO STOP
LIVING THE KIND OF LIFE THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN ACCUSTOMED TO. AS
I JUST WANT TO POINT THAT OUT.
AND REYES THE OBVIOUS OF. THE
INTENTIONS MAY BE NOBLE. BUT THE
EFFECT IS REALLY DETRIMENTAL TO
THE PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE AND
THAT'S THE KIND OF FRUSTRATION
AND DIFFICULTIES THAT ARE ENERGY
PEOPLE IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
HAVE TO FACE. THERE'S A REASON
THEY'RE DOING WHAT THEY'RE DOING
. THEY REACHING TWO ELECTRONS
THAT WE HAVE AND THAT'S
AVAILABLE AT A TIME THAT WE NEED
TO. AND I THINK THAT WE OUGHT TO
RECOGNIZE AND UNDERSTAND THE
DILEMMA- THAT WE ARE CREATING BY
THE POLICIES THAT WE ARE ARE
PURSUING. AND WHEN WE RELY ON
THE IMPORTATION. OF ELECTRICITY
FROM FROM OTHER STATES. IN A AYE
AYE POSITIONS THEY SAY WHAT ARE
WE GONNA DO STRIP SEARCH THOSE
ELECTRONS AT THE BORDER. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE MORAL OR
IMMORAL- WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
THAT OBLIGATIONS TO PROVIDE
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE ELECTRICITY.
TO THE PEOPLE CALIFORNIA WHEN
THEY NEEDED REGARDLESS OF THE
TIME OF DAY AND I THINK WE'RE
MISSING THAT MARK. THANK YOU- I
THINK WE'VE GOTTEN THAT PRETTY
FAR AFIELD FROM THE CORE
QUESTION HERE- THAT THE CHAIR
WAS ASKING WHICH IS- WHERE'S THE
UNDERLYING INFORMATION-
REGARDING- A FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT-
BUDGET REQUEST- THAT IS THE
TOPIC. OF THIS HEARING AS FOR
THE SUBJECT OF- LIKE TRENDS AND
YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW WE CAN WE
CAN- OF MOVE THIS INTO A DEBATE
ABOUT THE CLIMATE CRISIS BUT THE
REASON WE TALK ABOUT CLEAN
ENERGY THEM THE REASON- WE ARE
MOVING. AS QUICKLY AND AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE- A
TOWARDS CLEAN ENERGY IS THAT WE
ARE. EXPERIENCING THE CLIMATE
CRISIS IN REAL TIME WITH
WILDFIRE WITH EXTREME HEAT WITH-
OF THE MANY OTHER SYMPTOMS THAT
WE SEE OF A CHANGING CLIMATE
THAT IS DIRECTLY RELATED TO A IN
MANY WAYS TO THE PRODUCTION. AND
THE CONSUMPTION OF ENERGY FROM-
OF- CARBON HEAVY SOURCES WE
COULD THE UP MOVE BACK TO COAL
FIRED THE PRODUCTION OF ENERGY
IF WE WANTED TO- BUT THAT WOULD
PROVE TO ONLY. HASTEN THE OF
VERY MANY SYMPTOMS THAT WE SEE.
OTHER OF A RELATE TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS SET UP MR BENNETT LET'S
TRY TO STAY ON THE TOPIC HERE
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE A QUESTION
THAT RELATES TO- OUR EARLIER
CONVERSATION ARE HOPING THAT
THERE'S SOMEBODY. HERE STILL
MIGHT BE ABLE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION THAT YOU DIDN'T ASK
EARLIER THANK YOU AND I WILL.
HAVE- HE'S MY QUESTION A
TRANSITION THE OTHER WAY I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT ABOUT WE
COULD GO TO COAL AND PEOPLE
COULD CONSUME ALL THE
ELECTRICITY WATER BETWEEN FOUR
O'CLOCK AND AT AT AT HIGHS. NOT
AND NOBODY IS SAYING THAT YOU
SUGGESTED THAT- I DON'T WANNA I. DON'T WANNA I. THERE WAS A-
YOU CAN ALL AGREE THE MORALITY
OF ELECTRONS- THERE ARE LOTS OF
THINGS MY POINT IS THERE ARE
LOTS OF THINGS THAT WE COULD BE
TALKING ABOUT- THAT. RELATE TO
THE- TOPIC OF ENERGY AND THE
FUNDAMENTAL ONE THAT I THINK IS-
SET OF CONCERN HERE IS THE
CLIMATE CRISIS MR BENNETT ALL GO
. SO TOO SO WITH THAT I THINK IT
IS AN APPROPRIATE TRANSITION AT
AS WE ARE MAKING THE TRANSITION
FROM- CARBON HEAVY ENERGY TO
CLEAN ENERGY- THERE WILL BE
DISLOCATIONS. AND THAT JUST
INEVITABLE THAT HAPPENS
EVERYWHERE WHENEVER YOU CHANGE A
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S OUT THERE SO
MY QUESTION RELATES TO THIS AND
THAT IS DEMAND RESPONSE IS ONE
OF THE APPROACHES THAT WE CAN
USE- TO- TO- HELP US WHEN WE GET
THESE CRISIS WHEN THERE'S A-
WHEN THERE IS ELECTRICITY-
SHORTAGE FOR SOME REASON WHEN
THERE'S HEAVY DEMAND WHEN
THERE'S MORE DEMAND ON THE GRID
CAN HANDLE. AND SO WE HAVE A
HOPE WE HAVE A- DEMAND RESPONSE
PROGRAM OUT THERE RIGHT NOW MY
QUESTION IS FOR THE C. P. U. C.
A. N. FOR- THE DIRECTOR A
DIRECTOR BONHAM. ABOUT THIS
WHOLE ISSUE OF DEMAND RESPONSE A
SPECIFIC QUESTION FOR THE CPUC.
IS THIS IF WE IF WE STILL HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE THERE AND THAT
IS- LAST MAY YOU HAD A HEARING
AND YOU INDICATED YOU'D BE
TRYING TO. EXPLORE THAT NEW WAYS
THAT WE COULD REDUCE AND SHIFT
THE DEMAND LOAD- WHEN WE HAVE
THESE CRISIS- BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE HAS
BEEN NO. NOTHING'S HAPPENED
SINCE LAST MAY IN TERMS OF
BEGINNING THAT PROCESS- COULD
YOU ANSWER WHERE THE CPUC IS ON
SHIFTING ON ON- YOU HAD A
WORKSHOP IN MAY AND THEN ON ON
YOUR COMMITMENT. THEN- TO I TRY
TO FIND A WAY TO CREATE A UP.
FOR CUSTOMERS TO PARTICIPATE IN
DEMAND RESPONSE AND MY QUESTION
TO IT TO GET READY FOR THE- THE
DIRECTOR IS THE WHOLE ISSUE OF
DEMAND RESPONSE- IS ONE OF THE
TOOLS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE IN
OUR POCKET. IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S
DOMINATED BY THE INDEPENDENT
OPERATORS AT THIS POINT TIME AND
WITH TECHNOLOGY CHANGING THERE
SHOULD BE MANY OTHER
POSSIBILITIES FOR US TO DO
DEMAND RESPONSE- IN MY QUESTION
WOULD BE- HOW ARE WE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO BRING THE PRIVATE SECTOR
AND TO HELP US- WITH DEMAND
RESPONSE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO AGAIN TO
ADDRESS. THE DISLOCATIONS OF
THAT. BY FRANKLY YOU'RE
REFERRING TO WITH WITH YOUR
COMMENTS YES THERE ARE GOING TO
BE DISLOCATIONS THE QUESTION IS
HOW WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE NOT THAT WE CAN
GUARANTEE THERE WILL BE NO
DISLOCATIONS AS WE MAKE THIS
MASSIVE SHIFT. FROM FOSSIL FUEL
FUEL PRODUCED ENERGY TO CLEAN
ENERGY- SO- CPUC OR THE DIRECTOR
ON THE ISSUE A DEMAND RESPONSE
THE TWO QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT AND
CHAIR BLUE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS RACHEL
PETERSON AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE C. P. U. C. ARE
WE ARE VERY GLAD TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING WE HAVE OUR NEXT ITEM
OURSELVES ON YOUR AGENDA. AND IN
THE MEANTIME- WE ACTUALLY DO
HAVE SOMEONE ON READY TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION IT SIMON BAKER WHO
IS. THE LEAD. OR COMMAND
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES IN OUR
ENERGY EFFICIENT SO OVER TO SIGN
IN PLEASE THANK YOU. HI GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. YEAH SO THAT'S THANK
YOU SEE I THROUGH UTILITY
ADMINISTERED UTILITY PROGRAMS
HAS BEEN- ADVANCE ADVANCING
DEMAND RESPONSE FOR DECADES AND
IN RESPONSE TO THIS MOST RECENT.
RELIABILITY CRISIS WE REALLY DID
ROLL UP SLEEVES TO DO A LOT MORE
TO BRING MORE DEMAND RESPONSE TO
THE TABLE. IN A MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE DECISION TO QC
DIRECTED THE UTILITIES. TO DO A
NUMBER OF THINGS IN INCLUDING
LAUNCHING A BRAND NEW TEWIDE
PROGRAM CALLED THE EMERGENCY
LOAD REDUCTION. PILOT PROGRAM
WHICH WE EXPECT TO BRING IN A.
L. ON THE ORDER OF- SOME
HUNDREDS OF MEGAWATTS. AND WHAT
THAT DOES IS BASICALLY THAT WHEN
THE CHI SO CALLED AN EMERGENCY-
IT BRINGS AND LOAD REDUCTIONS
OUT FROM. CUSTOMERS BOTH
RESIDENTIAL AND NONRESIDENTIAL
INITIALLY IT WAS NON RESIDENTIAL
AND WE EXPANDED IT TO- TO
RESIDENTIAL AS WELL. WE ALSO
MODIFIED MANY OF THE EXISTING
UTILITY PROGRAMS UP TO INCREASE
HE INCENTIVES THAT WERE PAID-
AND MAKE OTHER MODIFICATIONS TO
MAKE THEM MORE- ACCEPTABLE TO
CUSTOMERS AND I'M AND WE ALL
STARTED HER IN A ROUGH YOU UP SO
I'M NOT TRYING TO. I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU IDENTIFYING THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE DONE AND I'M
I'M REALLY JUST TRYING TO FOCUS
ON- JUST TO SAVE EVERYBODY TIME
HERE IT WAS WITH A LONG
COMMITTEE HEARING AND SAVE YOU.
WHAT ARE WE- ARE WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO BE STARTING WHAT WHAT
WAS COMMITTED TO WHICH IS- THE
PROCESS OF- COULD BE MADE- IT
TAKING ACTION TO TRY TO CREATE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR CUSTOMERS
TO PARTICIPATE THERE'S- GONNA BE
A NEW EXPLORATION. IS DESERVES
ARE GONNA BE SOME NEW
EXPLORATION SO IF YOU HAVE
INFORMATION ON THAT I'D LIKE TO
HEAR. THE INFORMATION ON WHAT WE
ALREADY ARE DOING GOOD WOULDN'T
BE S. AS BENEFICIAL FOR ME IF. I
COULD POLITELY PUT IT THAT WAY.
COULD YOU HELP SURE WHAT'S OF IT
MAY BE THE ROLE OF THE- OF
THESE- OKAY FISHING HER PARTY.
SO OKAY YEAH SO WHAT THEM IS
THAT- WE ARE. AGAIN MORE
RECENTLY WE IN DECEMBER OF THIS
YEAR WE ACTUALLY EXPANDED THE
PARTICIPATION AND THAT-
EMERGENCY LOAD REDUCTION PROGRAM
TO AUTOMATICALLY ENROLL. ALL
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS INTO THE
PROGRAM AND SO THAT'S IN OUT
ROLL OUT RIGHT NOW AND SO WE
WILL SEE THIS SUMMER FOR THE
FIRST TIME THAT EXPANSION- SO
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS NEW.
WE'RE ALSO SEEING- A NEW PROGRAM
TO BE ABLE TO PILOT- WHAT ARE
CALLED VIRTUAL POWER PLANTS SO
THESE ARE A BEHIND THE METER
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES BEING USED
AS DEMAND RESPONSE- TO BE ABLE
TO EXPORT SOME OF THAT STORAGE
CAPACITY THAT WILL BE.
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE FIRST TIME
NOW COMING UP THIS SUMMER- AND
WE ARE. CONTINUING TO EXPAND
OUR- AVAILABILITY OF
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIRD PARTY
DEMAND RESPONSE AGGREGATORS. TO
PARTICIPATE IN PRICE- MARKETS
AND ENERGY MARKETS AND- TO
ACQUIRE CAPACITY PAYMENTS
THROUGH OUT LOAD SERVING
ENTITIES- RESOURCE ADVOCACY
PROGRAM SO THOSE ARE JUST THAT A
FEW OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING- THAT ARE EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DEMAND
RESPONSE. IF IF WE COULD JUST A
COMMENT AND I HAVE TO SORT OF A
QUESTION ALSO FOR THE- A
DIRECTOR BOTTOM IF- IF YOU CAN
RESPOND AND THAT IS TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN. DECREASE
OBSTACLES FOR EVERYBODY
CUSTOMERS PRIVATE PARTIES OF
PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN THIS FIELD THAT WE
CAN DECREASE BARRIERS FOR THEM
TO PARTICIPATE- AND GET INVOLVED
IN TRYING TO HELP US DEAL WITH
THE ISSUE DEMAND RESPONSE I
THINK THAT'S BENEFICIAL FOR- FOR
ALL OF US IN CALIFORNIA IF WE
CAN DO THAT- DIRECTOR BONHAM
DAY. YOU HAVE A ANY ANY THOUGHTS
ON- ON THAT ASPECT. THANK YOU SO
I WILL JUMP IN FOR- DIRECTOR
PAUL AND- HE IS AND ABSENCES
MEETING FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION BUT- FOR DEMAND
RESPONSE. MY NAME'S WE SHOULD
TEAR AS- SIMON ALREADY TALKED
ABOUT- SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER ON. AND I
JUST WANTED TO- REITERATE THE
COMMENTS EARLY ABOUT- THE AGENTS
WORKING. AND RESPONDING- WITH D.
W. OURS ARE. TEMPORARY BACKUP
GENERATORS- WE ARE- WE HAVE BEEN
SINCE AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
WORKING VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER-
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
RELIABLE SYSTEM AND BRING ALL
THE RESOURCES TO BEAR. SO- ON
THIS QUESTION OF DEMAND RESPONSE
ARE WE ARE SUPPORTING- THE CQC
AND EXPLORING- NEW WAYS TO BRING
<c.magenta>ORE DEMAND RESPONSE- TO MAKE</c>
SURE THE ACCOUNTING METHODOLOGY
IS APPROPRIATE AND- BENEFITS.
ARE CONSUMERS BUT ALSO ON. BUT
AT MAXIMIZER THE AMOUNT OF
DEMAND RESPONSE AVAILABLE TO THE
STATE SO AND THAT IS A PROCESS
THAT WE'RE WORKING ON NOW. AND
AND WE HAVE HELD MANY WORKING
GROUP MEETINGS WITH- DEMAND
RESPONSE PROVIDERS- ARE LOOKING
FOR THE BEST OPTIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THE- DEMAND RESPONSES
PROPERLY CAPTURED- FOR RESOURCE
ADEQUACY PURPOSES- TO THE EXTENT
THAT TO THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN
REDUCE THE EXPENSE AND YET YOU
KNOW WHEN AND OF BEING INVOLVED
IN THAT PROCESS I WOULD JUST
LEAVE IT AT THAT AND HOPE THAT-
THAT WE CAN FIND WAYS TO TRY TO
REDUCE THE EXPENSE OF EVERYBODY
BEING INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT THAT'S
A QUESTION STATE THANK YOU WE'LL
TAKE A BRIEF MOMENT TO- TO ASK
MS RIVAS TO ADD ON TO- OF THE
ATTENDANCE. RIVAS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU I KNOW THAT WAS THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE OF THE DAY-
WE'LL MOVE ON NOW TO- ISSUE
THREE. AND- THAT'S THE ICPC
AUDIT TO A TRAILER BILL AND TED
MISTER PETERSON- I BELIEVE
YOU'LL BE. PROVIDING US WITH THE
BACKGROUND ON THAT. YES GOOD
MORNING CHAIR RACHEL PETERSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE
THIS MORNING- TO PRESENT ON A
PROPOSED CHANGE THAT WE WITH
THAT- WE ARE SEEKING TO MAKE. OF
IN OUR AUDIT SEEING ON OF THE
ELECTRIC GAS WATER AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ENTITIES THAT
ARE UNDER AUDIT AUTHORITY- AND
AS YOU ARE AWARE JUST TO TAKE A
STEP BACK WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
TO DO IS TO MODIFY EXISTING
AUDIT REQUIREMENTS FOR THOSE
ENTITIES. FROM EIGHT LEADING HER
HÌNH DRIVEN METHODOLOGY TO A
RISK BASED METHODOLOGY AND
SPECIFICALLY THE PROPOSAL
REQUEST AMENDMENTS TO PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE SECTIONS THREE
ONE FOUR POINT FIVE. SEVEN NINE
TWO POINT FIVE AND TWO SEVEN
FOUR THAT WOULD ALIGN WITH AUDIT
AND INDUSTRY CURRENT BEST
PRACTICES WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
THIS WOULD MAKE IT OUR OFFICE
MORE. IMPACTFUL FOR RATEPAYERS.
CHANGES WOULD INTO A BASED MY-
TO ALL OF THE AUDITS THAT WERE
REQUIRED TO PERFORM. FOR THESE
REGULATED INDUSTRIES AND JUST TO
PROVIDE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF HOW IT
WOULD PLAY OUT- IF GRANTED THIS-
PROPOSAL EVERY YEAR WE WOULD
EXAMINE ALL OF THE ENTITIES THAT
WE COULD AUDITS. IDENTIFY AND
RISKS AND THOSE THAT
IDENTIFICATION OF RISKS WOULD
HELP US CREATE AN ANNUAL AUDIT
PLAN. AND EVALUATE THE RISK
ACCORDING TO THE REAL TIME
EVENTS IN EACH INDUSTRY. SO FOR
EXAMPLE. AS YOU PARTY NOTED AS
YOUR MEMBERS THE PARTY NOTED
TODAY. BUT INDUSTRY FACING
SIGNIFICANT IT GREAT INCREASES
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF COULD BE A
RISK THAT PLAYS INTO OUR- RISK
ASSESSMENTS AND THUS OUR AUDIT
PLAN IN OUR DECISION ABOUT WHICH
ENTITIES TO AUDIT. OTHER
EXAMPLES OF RISKS THAT WE MIGHT
THINK ABOUT WOULD BE THE OVERALL
REVENUE BALANCE OF AN ENTITY SO
A SIZE LARGER REVENUE BALANCES
WOULD LEND ITSELF TO MORE
INTEREST FROM AN AUDITING
PERSPECTIVE. THE LENGTH OF TIME
SINCE AN ENTITY ENTITY WAS LAST
AUDITED. AND THEN WHETHER OUR
AUDITS AUDITORS OR ANOTHER
ENTITY HAVE FOUND. ANY ISSUES IN
PASSED AUDITS. NOW WHAT WOULD
NOT CHANGE UNDER THIS. ARE THOSE
THAT WE FALL. OUR AUDIT DIVISION
PERFORMS EVERY AUDIT ACCORDING
TO GOVERNMENT AUDITING STANDARDS
AND THERE WOULD BE NO CHANGE TO
THAT PRACTICE. THIS IS ONLY
ABOUT CHANGING HOW WE DECIDE
WHICH ENTITIES TO AUDIT ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. WITH THIS CHANGE I
WOULD HAVE BETTER ABILITY TO
DIRECT OUR AUDITING DIVISION
TOWARD HIGHER RISK ENTITIES. WE
WOULD HAVE BETTER ABILITY TO
RESPOND IN REAL TIME TO EVENTS
AND ULTIMATELY DRIVE OUT THAT
AUDITING VALUE THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT AND SO IMPACTFUL FOR
REPAIRS. THERE'S A CLEANUP
LANGUAGE IN THE- PROPOSAL AS
WELL- BUT THERE WAS MY REMARKS
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE NOT NOT A QUESTIONS YET-
WILL I HEAR FROM THE ALEJO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- STOP ON
THIS ISSUE- IN CONCEPT WE
SUPPORT THE OVERALL INTENT TO
USE THE A RISK BASED APPROACH TO
AUDITING AS A MORE EFFICIENT WAY
TO ALLOCATE RESOURCES. HOWEVER
AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
MODIFICATIONS TO THE PROPOSAL
INCLUDING. KEEPING REQUIREMENTS
FOR LARGE AUDITS OR A REGULAR
AUDITS OF LARGE UTILITIES WITH
SUBSTANTIAL AUDIT FINDINGS WHILE
ALSO PROVIDINGSOME FLEXIBILITY
MAY BE FOR LESS FREQUENT AUDITS
OF THE SMALLER LESS RISKY
UTILITIES SO. SOMETHING LIKE
THIS COULDSTRIKE A MORE- MORE
OF A MIDDLE GROUND BETWEEN KIND
OF PROVIDES MORE FLEXIBILITY
WHILE ALSO MAINTAINING SOME
MINIMUM LEVEL OF REQUIREMENTS
FOR THAT THE LARGER RISK.
UTILITIES SO THERE'S INTEREST BY
THE COMMITTEE IN THE LEGISLATURE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE
IN YOUR STOP TO EXPLORE THESE
TYPES OF MODIFICATIONS AS THE
REMAINDER OF. THE BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS GO FORWARD. THANK
YOU JUST A PART IN A- HAVE ANY
TO ADD. NEVADA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME ALTHOUGH WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANKS
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON HAS QUESTION. WELL NO
I MEAN I WAS THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL. AB TEN SEVENTY TWO WAS
INTRODUCED IN TWENTY NINETEEN.
THIS WAS IN RESPONSE TO THE
STATE AUDITOR'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT ON THE TRANSPARENCY OF
WATER RATE INCREASES. AND AMONG
THE STATE AUDITOR'S FINDINGS WAS
THAT THE CPC WAS NOT CONDUCTING
AUDITS AS FREQUENTLY AS
REQUIRED. AND THERE WAS A
CONCERN EXPRESSED THAT SOME OF
THE AUDITS THAT WERE CONDUCTED
DID NOT FULFILL THE INTENT OF
THE LAW. AB TEN SEVENTY TWO
PROVIDED. CLARITY TO THE SMALL
WATER AND TELEPHONE PROVIDERS
ABOUT THE TIMELINE AND THE
STANDARDS ON WHICH THE CPUC MUST
COMPLETE AN AUDIT. OR REVIEW OF
THEIR UTILITIES. THESE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN ONGOING CONCERN FOR
THE SMALL REGULATE WATER SYSTEMS
IN MY DISTRICT AND OTHERS
STATEWIDE. THE BILL WAS NEEDED
TO ENSURE THAT THE CPUC COMPLIES
WITH THE AUDITING STANDARDS
OUTLAWED STATUTE IN A TIMELY AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER. AT MEMBERS
THIS BILL PASSED THE LEGISLATURE
SEVENTY FOUR TO NOTHING. AND WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR INTO LAW
. IT REQUIRED THAT THE P. YOU
SEE. AUDIT IN THE SPECIFIC AREAS
WITHIN THAT FIVE YEAR PERIOD AND
INSISTED IN THE LEGISLATION THAT
THE AUDIT MUST THESE AUDIT
SHOULD BE COMPLETED BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. NONE OF THOSE AUDITS
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED AS YET. SO
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS ACTED THE
GOVERNOR HAS SIGNED. AND NOW WE
SEE A REPEAL EFFORT. I HAVE TEN
SEVENTY TWO BY A BUDGET. AND RUN. THEY WANT TO REPEAL TEN
SEVENTY TWO. THEN TAKE IT UP
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. BUT TO DO
THIS IN THIS MANNER. IS TO ASK
THE QUESTION WHAT GIVES THIS A
PRIORITY. TO UNDERMINE THE
DIRECT AND EXPRESSED WILL THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE AND IT
LEADS ME TO ASK THE QUESTION
WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO HIDE. OF
ALL ASSUME THAT'S A RHETORICAL
QUESTION A QUESTION BEING ASKED
OF THE- A- QUESTION. AND DOUG SO
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE- WE WILL
NOW I'LL I'LL ASK IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM OR
MEMBERS ON NON DISCUSSION ITEMS
ON THE AGENDA. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THEN WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. EVERYONE WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE TO SPEAK AS I
INDICATED EARLIER- IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
GET PUBLIC COMMENT. SEEING NONE-
ALL REMIND THOSE WAITING TO GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE.
THAT THE PHONE NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE ONE THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR
FOUR SEVEN OPERATOR. DO WE HAVE
ANY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO GIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT. YES WE DO MISTER
CHAIR AND AS A REMINDER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO
PARTICIPATE WITH THE COMMENT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR PHONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE. TWENTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
MEMBERS DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT THE ONE BILLION PROPOSED
ONE BILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED TO
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALLOW
INCOME BUILDING RHETORIC AT
PROGRAM THAT COVERS GREEN
APPLIANCE THAT. ANALOG GREAT DAN
ENERGY EFFICIENCY WE'RE ALSO
COLLECTING ONE BILLION DOLLARS
TO CONSTRUCT AN UPGRADE
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS
LIKE SCHOOLS LIBRARIES AND OTHER
PUBLIC BELT. THIS CAN TO BILLION
DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT. WILL HELP REDUCE
CLIMATE CHANGE POLLUTION. AGAPE
THE IMPACTS OF EXTREME HEAT
CREATE GOOD PAYING JOBS AND
BUILD PLANTS CLIMATE RESILIENCE
FOR CALIFORNIA. ABOUT THE WONDER
QUICKLY COMMENT ON THE GREEN
HYDROGEN ABOUT THE WE KNOW
THERE'LL BE A ROLE FOR HYDROGEN
IN THE- FUTURE BUT WE BELIEVE
DUE TO IT EXPENSE IT SHOULD BE
RESERVED FOR VERY DIFFICULT TO
ELECTRIFY ACTORS. WE ALSO AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER BENNETT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD.
ALSO ON THE FINDER OF THE
RENEWABLE. HYDROGEN AND NOT
WASTE TIME ON BRIDGE TECHNOLOGY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT. THANK
YOU. I'LL GO TO LINE HAND. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS TREAT
THE COOK ON BEHALF OF ECUADOR-
THIS IS ONE OF THE OFFSHORE
WIND- COMPANIES VERY INTERESTED
IN DEVELOPMENT OFF THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
WANT TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR ITS ROBOTS SUPPORT AT EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY FIVE LAST YEAR THAT
THE- CHIU BILL THAT GOT THE BALL
BALL ROLLING ON PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT- THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FORTY FIVE
MILLION OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT.
GIVEN THE NEED TO ANALYZE
CAPABILITIES AND MAKE STRATEGIC
INVESTMENTS IN CAPITAL UPGRADE
SUPPORT AND LEVERAGE FEDERAL
FUNDING THE INDUSTRY IS
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING AN
INCREASE TO ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS- TO DEVELOP YOU KNOW
ABOUT FOR THE TEN GIGAWATTS OF
OFFSHORE WIND POWER IN THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS THANK YOU AND
APPRECIATE THAT GOOD DIALOGUE ON
THE TOPIC EARLIER. LINE. TWENTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BEDS WERE
LARGER WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER
OF. THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT WE WANT TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION GENERAL LEADING
TOWARDS CLIMATE BUT WANTED TO
EXPRESS THE FACT THAT WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THERE WERE NO
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENTS AND
LOCAL ENERGY PRESENT
TECHNOLOGIES MEASURES- WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY HERE EIGHT THIRTY
THREE. WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
PLANNING BONDS FOR GENIE ENERGY
RESILIENCE PLANS AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND WE WOULD URGE
THE LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT THAT EFFORT.
ADDITIONALLY WITH MICROLINER
COMMENTS WITH THE SIERRA CLUB'S
TO INVEST IN THE INITIAL
INVESTMENT OF ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE NUTRACEUTICAL
COUNCIL COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
HEALTH PROGRAM. AND FINALLY WE
RECOMMEND THAT YOUR BILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND BE
ALLOCATED OVER SEVERAL YEARS TO
FIND BEHIND THE- OUR SELECTED
PROJECTS WERE CRITICAL SO IF.
THEIR TURN TO COMMENT THANK YOU
. WHY TWENTY NINE. THANK YOU
TURN MAKE YOU COPY WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL UNDER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR EQUITABLE
DUTY CAR PROGRAM WHICH SONG WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING TARGETED
TOWARDS LOW INCOME RESIDENTS TO
PROVIDE EFFICIENT ALL ELECTRIC
HEAT PUMP FOR COOLING ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND BUILDING
INFLATION AND FEELING HOWEVER WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE MINISTRATION ON DESIGNING
A PROGRAM THAT WILL PREVENT
DISPLACEMENT AND RENT INCREASES
AND ALLOW FOR HABITABILITY AND
OTHER HEALTH RELATED IMPROVEMENT
TO ENSURE THAT WE MAKE THE MOST
OF THE DEPARTMENT BASSINET. AND
A COMPLEMENT OF ABOUT FIFTY
SUPPORT INVESTING ADDITIONAL
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AN UPGRADED
COMMITTEE REBELLION CENTER THE
PROCEDURE GROWTH CAPITAL WHICH
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE PROPOSED%
FUNDING FOR THE INDUSTRIAL
DECARBONISATION PROGRAMME
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR IS THE MAJOR
SOURCE OF EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION BUT IT'S YOURS BEHIND
OTHER SECTORS IN DECARBONIZING
IS THE BEST NUMBER NEED IT
HIGHLIGHTED FANCY COLLEGES THAT
WILL SUPPORT WORKING CLASS JOBS.
IT FUNDING MUST BE CONDITION
THOUGH ON ENSURING THAT PROJECTS
DELIVER COMMUNITY BENEFIT THAT
ALIGN WITH OUR CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS AND FINALLY ON
THE PROPOSED FUNDING FOR
HYDROGEN I WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
PROGRAM AT THE ENERGY COMMISSION
TO DEVELOP HYDROGEN MARKET IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE URGE YOU TO
RETAIN A FOCUS ON ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN MADE WITH CLEAN
ELECTRICITY ELECTROLYZER
TECHNOLOGY WHICH HAS THE MOST
POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE YOU BOOK-
CENTER AND WE APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER POLICEMEN BENNETT
COMMENT ON THAT EARLIER THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY. I THANK.
THANK YOU. I AM VERY MUCH THREE.
SHE CARE NUMBER STERLING HUNTER
FIRST BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC
ENERGY ONE EXPECT PARTS STRONG
SUPPORT AND APPRECIATE FOR THE
OVERALL PACKAGE ESPECIALLY ON
THE FOCUS ON BUILDING A
COMBINATION FONG AND INCLUSION
OF FUNDING FOR KARNAL. AND
SECONDLY ON BEHALF OF HAIDAR
STORE WE ARE A LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE COMPANY WORKING
HARD ON YOUR PROJECT CALIFORNIA
WHEN I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION-
FOR THAT ROBOTS NUMBER OF THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR LONG DURATION ENERGY
STORAGE. BUT I THINK WE WANNA
OKAY- AND HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
NOT ONLY- PILOT PROJECTS OR
THINGS THAT ARE COMING TO THE
MARKET BUT ALSO THE FIRST OF THE
CURRENT PROJECT I THINK THERE
ARE LARGER AND CAN ACTUALLY
PROVIDE REAL TIME WOULD BENEFIT
IN THE NEAR TERM. I'M TOTALLY
BLANK THANK YOU- WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HOW THAT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE COULD BE OKAY- CHU
HIGHLIGHT AND BRING FORWARD
LARGER PROJECT GOOD THING- THAT
ARE ALREADY COMMERCIAL BUT NEED
HELP GETTING ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE STORE THAT WILL BREAK THAT.
IN THE NEAR TERM THANK. YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW GOING
TO GO LAW UP FOR THREE. FINING
SHERRIN MEMBERS AND LEFT HOW
WE'RE TRYING TO PRESS CONSULTING
ON BEHALF OF THE GOVERNMENT I'M
FUND ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ALLIANCE IN CALIFORNIA
BERMAN TOLD VOTERS. WE SUPPORT
THE ONE BILLION PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR LOW INCOME
BUILDING RETROFIT PROGRAM THAT
COVERS COULD APPLIANCES PANEL
UPGRADES AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY
WE ARE ALSO REQUESTING ONE
BILLION TO CONSTRUCT AN UPGRADE
COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS
LIKE SCHOOLS LIBRARIES AND OTHER
PUBLIC BUILDINGS. THAT COMBINE
TWO MILLION INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT WILL HELP REDUCE
CLIMATE POLLUTION MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF EXTREME HEAT CREATE
GOOD PAYING JOB AND BILL CREDIT
RESILIENCE. FOR CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FINE.
THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING I'M
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ARE COMING TO BEEN
HIT REALLY HARD BY WILDFIRES IN
BOTH PLANNED AND UNPLANNED
OUTAGES OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS INTERVIEW RELIABILITY
SHARPLY DECLINED IN MANY OF OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THERE'S NOT REALLY
STEEP INCREASE IN ENERGY GRIDS
OF THE LAST FEW YEARS THIS IS
ALL TROUBLING IS THE STATE'S
SIXTY TRANSITION TO ELECTRIC
POWER TRANSPORTATION SECTOR SO
WE SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
STATE'S INTEREST IN INVESTING IN
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
AFFORDABILITY AND RELIABILITY AT
THE SAME TIME WE BELIEVE THERE
IS ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT AND WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER THIS MORNING
OUTLINING OUR SUGGESTIONS IN
BRIEFWE CAN GET SUGGESTED
DEVELOPING ABOUT THREE AND A
HALF BILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO OFFSET RATE INCREASES
RELATED UTILITY WHILE APARTMENT
GAUGE NETWORKS THIS ALLIANCE
WITH ITS CHIEF UC'S EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS ENERGY AFFORDABILITY
INCLUDING SHIFTING SOME REPAIR
PROGRAMS THE GENERAL FUND. WE
ALSO SUGGEST ALLOCATING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY KNOWING TO SPORTS
SMALLER LONG DURATION PUMP
STORAGE GEOTHERMAL AND BIOMASS
PROJECTS TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
LOCAL RESILIENCY BENEFITS AND
THEN FINALLY ADDING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TO DEPLOY REMOTE GRIDS
AND RURAL AREAS TO ENSURE LOCAL
ENERGY RELIABILITY AND REDUCE
WILDFIRE RISK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY IN YOUR COUNTRY. THAT THE
ISSUE YEAH THANK YOU. NOW GOOD
TO GO TO LINE. FORTY TWO. HI
GOOD MORNING MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS TRICIA GARINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS AND
FARMER AND BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL OF
PROVIDING. EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND TO THE FOOD
PRODUCTION INVESTMENT PROGRAM AS
CHIP. BACKING GRANT PROGRAM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATUS IS
BEING PRUDENT WHEN PRODUCERS AND
PROCESSORS IN THEIR EFFORT TO
CONSIDERABLY REDUCE ENERGY USE
AND LOWER CARBON EMISSIONS BY
REPLACING HIGH ENERGY EQUIPMENT
WITH ADVANCED TO CLEANER BURNING
ENERGY TECHNOLOGIES. DIFFICULTLY
AFFECT THE COST PER KIND OF
TEACH YOU REDUCE THAT'S THE
FOURTH BEST OF ALL CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE INVESTMENTS PROGRAMS AT
THREE THREE DOLLARS PER METRIC
TONS OF CARBON DIOXIDE A QUICK
LITTLE IT. FURTHER ACCORDING TO
THE ANALYSIS AND CARVE THE
TECHNOLOGY. AND Q. CARBON. 85%
OF SPENDING IS TOWARD PROJECTS
LOCATED DISADVANTAGED AND
MYLINCOLN. COMMUNITIES WHICH
FURTHER SAYS THAT THE OF THE
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS THE ALLEY OF
COMMERCE ABOUT FEDERAL DOLLARS
THERE IS NOT A PROGRAM SIMILAR
TO ACTIVE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
TO THE STATE IS LEADING ON CLEAN
ENERGY WITH THE PROGRAM AND
SERVING AS A MODEL FOR OTHERS.
WITH THAT WE ENCOURAGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SUPPORT AT THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATION OF EIGHTY
FIVE PLAN FOR APPS KEPT IN THE
BUDGET TO CONTINUE THIS
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE TWO
FACTOR. AND THE STATE TO CALORIE
CLEAN ENERGY AND CARBON. GOALS
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MEANWHILE
CREAMERS WITH WINE INSTITUTE AND
I'M ALSO HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE FOOD PRODUCTION
INVESTMENT PROGRAMS. OVER 80% OF
CALIFORNIA WINE IS PRODUCED IN A
CERTIFIED SUSTAINABLE WINERY AND
THOSE WINERIES ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING TO CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE.
THEIR OPERATIONS AND MAKE THEM
MORE SUSTAINABLE AND AFTER
PROGRAM CAN PLAY A KEY ROLE IN
HELPING REDUCE. OR IMPROVE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION
INCLUSION AND EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION. IN THEIR PROPOSED
BUDGET AND URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
ALTERNATELY INCLUDE THAT IN THE
FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE. NINETEEN GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BUYING
LIKE ON BEHALF OF OFFSHORE WIND
CALIFORNIA EIGHT BUSINESS TRADE
GROUP OF OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPERS AND TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
THE RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT
OFFSHORE WIND POWER COMMENTING
ON THE CLEAN ENERGY PACKAGE OR
THE DC SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO DEDICATE FORTY FIVE
MILLION FOR FACILITY PLANNING
AND DEVELOPMENT THAT CORPS THIS
WILL HELP SPUR AFTER WIND ENERGY
IN FEDERAL WATERS OFF
CALIFORNIA'S COAST. AND IT'S
ALSO IN LINE WITH BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S NATIONWIDE THIRTY
GIGAWATT AFTER WHEN GOAL IS NOT
MEET THE- THE GOLDEN BENEFITS OF
THE S. B. ONE HUNDRED DON'T
AGENCY REPORT WE ALSO COMMEND
THE CC FOR ALSO TAKING THE LEAD
AND STARTING THE DISCUSSION TO
EIGHTY FIVE TWO FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION IT WOULD REQUIRE
STRATEGIC PLAN HOWEVER WE
BELIEVE TO FULLY RECOGNIZE THE
GOALS AND BENEFITS OF EMERGING
FLOATING OFFSHORE WIND
TECHNOLOGY. THE LEGISLATURE SENT
DEDICATE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS EFFORT THIS
WILL HELP BILL PORTS- HELP
LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS IT ALSO
HELPED KICKSTART A MULTI SPORT
STRATEGY WHICH IS NEEDED BUT THE
GOOD NEWS WE HAVE ONE COURT IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY WHICH IS ALREADY
AHEAD OF EVERYBODY ELSE BUT IN
THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE THE STATE
NEEDS TO IDENTIFY ANOTHER PORT
OR PORT THAT CAN ACCOMMODATE
LARGE SCALE OFFSHORE WIND
PROJECTS IN THE CENTRAL COAST A
PARTICULAR MORAL BAY. WHAT THE
FEDERAL LEASE SALE EXPECTED THIS
FALL ARE THERE WILL BE A LOT
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENSURE ADEQUATE
THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
TRANSMISSION OF PORT
INFRASTRUCTURE CAPACITY AND ALSO
ADDRESSING NATURAL RESOURCE
ISSUES A WE HAVE BROUGHT IN MORE
DETAIL LATER FOR YOU MR CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO DISCUSS
THIS NEED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING ABOUT A MILLION AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND. THE ADMINISTRATION ON THANK
YOU FOR THANK. NOW GOING TO GO
TO LAW TWENTY. MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN GOING TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN OFFSHORE WIND INFRASTRUCTURE
UPGRADE THE SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
GOING BACK ON OFFSHORE WIND
WITHOUT A CONCERTED EFFORT TO
INVEST IN PORT INFRASTRUCTURE
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO MISS
OUT ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS OF A ROBOT ACHTER WENT
THE PIE CHAIN. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES AN
ALLOCATION OF FORTY FIVE MILLION
PURPORTING FEASIBILITY STUDIES.
OR AMERICAN CLEAN POWER'S
REQUEST. THAT THE LEGISLATURE IN
BATON ADDITIONAL FIFTY FIVE
BILLION TO DEVELOP A PLAN BY THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY FO
GROWING CULTURE WIND.
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT
INVESTMENT MADE IN THE EQUITABLE
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
PROGRAMS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUESTS OF A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FORUM THAT ENERGY RESOURCES
PROGRAMS ACCOUNT. HELP
CALIFORNIA OVERCOME BARRIERS TO
ELECTRIFYING BOOSTING BILL
CLINTON THOUGHT ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING EQUIPMENT TO EXISTING
BUILDINGS. LASTLY IN PURSUIT OF
EXPANDING CLEAN ENERGY ACT THAT
ENCOURAGE THE TPC. TO SUPPORT
SOLAR NET METERING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE. THIRTY EIGHT.
HI THIS IS ALEX MORRIS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE AND CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSED THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE I HAVE A
COUPLE QUICK POINTS TO MAKE.
FIRST I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS A VERY BENEFIT
BENEFICIAL MOVE FOR CALIFORNIA
AS WE WORK TO INTEGRATE. VAST
AMOUNTS OF RENEWABLES AND CLEAN
OUR GREAT. WE WILL NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE SUFFICIENTLY
COMMERCIALIZED LONG DURATION
ENERGY STORAGE. AVAILABLE FOR
OUR UTILITIES AND CCA TO
PROCURE. AND CURRENTLY SOME OF
THAT COMMERCIALIZATION IS NOT
HAPPENING. THE GREAT SOME
RESOURCES ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO
COMPETE BECAUSE THEY HAVEN'T
COME FAR ENOUGH ALONG THE
COMMERCIALIZATION CURVES. AND
THROUGH THIS FUNDING WE CAN GET
MORE PROJECTS BILL HELPING YOUR
TERM WELL ALSO COMMERCIALIZING
THESE PROJECTS TO SAVE MONEY
LONGER TERM. I ALSO WANTED TO
SUPPORT THE PLAN FOR THAT THOSE
FUNDS TO FLOW THROUGH THE CDC.
THE CDC IS THE RIGHT AGENCY AND
HAS. THE RIGHT EXPERTISE TO
EVALUATE AND DISTRIBUTE THOSE
FUNDS PRUDENTLY ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S THE END OF MY
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOR AS A REMINDER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO MAKE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ONE NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE
FORTY SIX. AND FORTY SIX OF ONE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WITH MADDIE
MONTHS AND ON BEHALF OF THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
POULTRY FEDERATION CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER ONE THE
CLEAN ENERGY PACKAGE AND
PARTICULARLY THE FOOD PROCESSOR
INVESTMENT PROGRAM. AT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND MY COLLEAGUES
FROM ACT COUNCIL NOTED THIS IS A
VERY COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM HAVE
BEEN GREATLY OVERSUBSCRIBED. WE
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
CURRENT DEFINITION GREEN
HYDROGEN IN THE PACKAGE AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS
ON THIS MUCH NEEDED IMPORTANT
PROGRAM. WE'D ALSO LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF THE L. A. O. ON
THE MERITS OF FUNDING A PROGRAM
THROUGH THE GENERAL FUND RATHER
THAN RAPIDLY RISING ENERGY RATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. LINE. FORTY NINE. I'M GOOD
MORNING THIS IS MIKE ROBESON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR SAID CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENT PACKAGE- I'M A SENIOR
I BELIEVE THAT SINCE-
RESPONSIBLE USE OF GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS ENSURES THAT RATEPAYERS
DO NOT SOLELY CHILDREN COSTS AND
THEREBY DISCOURAGE BROADER
ELECTRIFICATION EFFORTS UNTIL
YOU CREATE THAT. AND WE WOULD
JUST SIMPLY ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE- SURE THE PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
A GRANT SINCE PROGRAM AND TO
ENSURE THAT- THAT CUSTOMERS AND
BE ELIGIBLE FOR ELECTRIC SERVICE
GOT- SELECTRIC SERVICE UPGRADES
AS PART OF THE BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION PROGRAM IN
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHY. FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND YOUR ANSWER HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF ADVANCED ENERGY
ECONOMY- WE ARE A TRADE GROUP
AND MY MADE UP OF BUSINESSES
FOCUSED ON CLEAN RELIABLE
ENERGY- WE'RE HERE TODAY TO- GET
ON THE RECORD OUR SUPPORT FOR
THE SUBSTANTIAL CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY
INVESTMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET AND WE WELCOME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WTH YOU
ON THE SOME COMMUTING OTHERS IN
THE LEGISLATURE TO FILL ANY
EXISTING GAPS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ADDRESSED- A DOUBLY
SUPPORTS THE PROPOSED BUDGET YOU
HAVE INVESTMENT PACKAGE. THAT
FOCUSES ON MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
INVESTMENTS AND EQUITY PROGRAMS
- WE REALLY SUPPORT RELIABLE
MULTI YEAR FUNDING AND WE THINK
THAT THE CENTRAL PROVIDING
CONTINUITY AND CERTAINTY- FOR
THE RELEVANT DOCUMENTS WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO SPEED
THE TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
SCHOOL BUSES STATEWIDE REACT THE
LOOKS LIKE A FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THESE DOLLARS FUND AS MANY
EUROVISION- SCHOOL BUSES AS
POSSIBLE. AND WHERE THEY'RE MOST. NEEDED AROUND THE STATE. WE
HAVE CONCERN ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
OF THE GRANT AMOUNTS LIMITATIONS
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE TO. WORK
WITH- THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
AND STAFF AND WE RECOMMEND-
LOOKING AT PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. TO THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT DO NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO NAVIGATE.THE
CURRENT STATE GRANT PROGRAM
THANK YOUR CAR WE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER. WILL NOW GO TO
WIDE THAT THE- THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBER OF TRITON
ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN IN POWER
CALIFORNIA EVERY LIKE THE LINE
THE COMMENTS MADE BY OTHERS WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNMENT
POSTAL. IN THE CLEAN ENERGY
ABOUT THE PACKAGE OF FORTY FIVE
MILLION CRAWFORD WHENEVER
REQUESTED ADDITIONAL FIFTY FIVE
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
POOR OPERATORS OR EXPANSION- AND
CREATE GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA. ALL BUILDING OUT-
BUT DOCTOR WHEN INDUSTRY. I WHEN
IS WILL BE CRITICAL. CAL MOVING
TO ACHIEVE. ARE THERE A GOLD
AFFORDABLE WHILE MAINTAINING
RELIABILITY AND AS OF TODAY
CALIFORNIA'S NOT HAVE BEEN A
VERY POOR INFRASTRUCTURE. TO BE
ABLE TO CONSTRUCT AND MAINTAIN
PUTTING OFF FOR WIND TURBINE.
YOU KNOW THAT MANY PORTS QUITE
SIGNIFICANT ABOUT THEM BY THE
STATE TO SUPPORT PORT NOT
CREATING ANYTHING IMPORTANT PATH
CITY AS WELL TO ATTRACT FEDERAL
MATCHING DOLLARS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WILL NOW GO TO LINE
FORTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS LESLIE
MARTINEZ WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WHERE AN ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
DIRECTLY WITH THEM THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
KENTUCKY VALIANTLY COACHELLA
VALLEY I'M CONNECT WILL THE
BUILDING TO CARBONIZATION WITH
DEPARTMENT JORDY OF THE FUNDING
THAT'S GOING TO TURN INTO A
PROGRAM FOR LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES- BUT WE WOULD LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
INVESTING IN CULTURALLY
APPROPRIATE OUTREACH EFFORT. AND
YOU KNOW IN BALLING THE
EXPERTISE OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING DIRECTLY ON THE GROUND
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE PRICES. ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
EFFICIENT AND- PERFICIENT AND-
EFFECTIVE THOSE BETTER DEAL WITH
COOL. AS WE WORK INTO A THEIR
THAT ARE MY- IN. BY WRITING
PEAK. AND I'M GREEN HYDROGEN
THAT WE DO- ASSET THE STATE
INVEST IN- HUNDRED THAT IS GREEN
AND PRODUCED WITHOUT THE USE OF
POLLUTING. FOSSIL FUELS AND
BIOMETHANE PRODUCED BY JERRY
THAT DR AND FINALLY ON UTILITY
DEBT MANY CALIFORNIANS. ARE
CONTINUE TO FEEL THE ECONOMIC
BURDEN OF UTILITY DOES A RESULT
OF KOBE TO CALL TWO BILLION
DOLLARS IN UTILITY BACK DEBT
RELIEF. BUT EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY
TO THIRD. PARTY DEBT THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. NOW GO TO
WINE FIFTY TWO. YES THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PUBLIC STREET ON
BEHALF OF THE PECHANGA INDIAN
RESERVATION AND THE PITCH ON THE
BAND OF THE SENIOR MISSION
INDIANS- WE JUST. WANTED THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK ON EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE IN CLEAN ENERGY THE
JUNGLE SUPPORTS CLEAN ENERGY BUT
WE ASK THAT YOU MAKE SURE THAT
ALL PUMPED STORAGE PROPOSAL- AND
CONSIDERATIONS ALSO WORK WITH
THE LOCAL TRIBES THERE ARE
STILL. A FEW SACRED SITES OUT
THERE THAT HAVE BEEN PELAGE DOOR
OR RUINED AND IT'S A BIG DEAL
BOTH TRIED ACTUALLY HAD- A LOT
OF THEIR RESERVATION NEAR. THE
WATER SOURCES AND RESOURCES AND-
JUST PLEASE KEEP IN MIND ON ANY
OF DORRIDGE WE KNOW THAT THE
OROVILLE PROJECT HAS WORK TO
TRY. BUT THERE ARE OTHER
PROJECTS AND. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS WE APPROACH THE
END OF THE COMMENTERS TO SIGNAL
BY WHICH TO MAKE A COMMENT FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO STILL WISH TO
MAKE COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ONE NOW GO TO LINE
FORTY EIGHT. HI MY NAME IS
JENNIFER BRANHAM THE FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT OF THE GREEN HYDROGEN
COALITION WHERE AN EDUCATIONAL
NONPROFIT WHOSE MISSION IS TO
ACCELERATE GREEN HYDROGEN. AT
SCALE TO DISABILITY MULTI
SECTORAL DEEP DECARBONIZATION
AND CLEAN AND JUST ENERGY
TRANSITION. WE APPLAUD
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING OUR CLIMATE CRISIS.
AND LEADING THE COUNTRY IN CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION AND FOR YOUR
HYDROGEN IN ACHIEVING THIS CALL.
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET FOR GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC. HYDROGEN PROJECTS.
FOSSIL FUEL COSTS ARE INCREASING
THE URGENCY OF EXPLORING
SCALABLE ALTERNATIVE. GREEN
HYDROGEN AS A COMMERCIALLY
VIABLE PATHWAY TO DAY. I HAVE A
FEW QUICK COMMENT IN LIGHT OF
THE EARLIER DISCUSSION. THE
FIRST IS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
MANY ABUNDANT FEEDSTOCKS FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF GREEN HYDROGEN.
INCLUDING AGRICULTURAL WASTE
POOREST WASTE AND MUNICIPAL
WASTE THAT CAN BE RESPONSIBLY
CONVERTED TO GREEN HYDROGEN TO
DATE. WE ENCOURAGE THE EXPANSION
OF OUR USE OF THESE STOCKTON
VALUABLE RESOURCES. GOING
FORWARD SECONDLY. INVESTMENT IN
PRODUCTION PATHWAYS ARE
IMPORTANT BUT SO IS INVESTMENT
IN DOWNSTREAM INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE LOW DELIVERED
COST WE APPRECIATE THE MANY
COMMENTS THAT OTHERS HAVE MADE
ABOUT THE NEED TO INVEST IN OUR
PORT. WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE
UPTAKE OF HIGH VOLUME NEAR TERM
MULTI SECTORAL OFF TAKERS
INCLUDING PORT OPERATIONS HARPER
CRAFT HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORT
AMMONIA PRODUCTION AIRPORT
OPERATIONS AND THE PRODUCTION OF
SYNTHETIC LIQUID FUELS. THAT CAN
DISPLAY EASEL AND A WHOLE RANGE
OF COCKTAILS AND LASTLY
CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETITIVELY
POSITIONED ITSELF. FOR AS MUCH
AS TWO BILLION OF THE EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR FEDERAL CLEAN AND
GREEN HYDROGEN HUB FUNDING THAT
WILL BE AWARDED LATER THIS YEAR. AND COULD WE RECOMMEND
CALIFORNIA. SURE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO SERVE MATCH FUNDING
AND MAKE CALIFORNIA SUPER
COMPETITIVE IN THIS NATIONAL
COMPETITION WHAT THE MIDDLE
LETTER OUTLINING OUR
RECOMMENDATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. LINE FIFTY
THREE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS- MY NAME WHEN THEY
TOWARDS THEM WHAT THE BUILDINGS
ARE COALITION I WANT TO BRING
YOUR ATTENTION CHILDREN LETTER
DATED FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND
THAT WE CAN THEN ALONG WITH THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS ALLIANCE
AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED. BY THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSED FOR APPLE BILLION
DECARBONISATION- WE WANT THE
BENEFITS OF THIS PROGRAM TO
PRIORITIZE CALIFORNIA'S LOW
INCOME AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AND- YOU KNOW TO
ALSO HAVE A PROGRAM DESIGNED
PRIORITIZE CENTER PROTECTIONS
AND A HOLISTIC HEALTH RELATED
IMPROVEMENTS- DISINVESTMENT
CRITICALLY PUTS US CLOSER
TOWARDS A HOLISTIC VISION FOR
HELPING CLIMBERS HOME FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ALSO
REQUESTING ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR COMMUNITY RESILIENCE CENTERS
LIKE SCHOOLS AND OTHER PUBLIC
BUILDINGS. WE BELIEVE THIS
COMBINED TWO BILLION DOLLAR
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IN THE
SHORT TERM WILL HELP REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS PRETTY GOOD
PAYING JOB THE BILL PRIMARY
RESILIENCE. FOR CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WILL THE FINAL FOR
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO MAKE
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. YOUR CHAIR THERE
IS NO ONE ELSE WOULD SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC COMMENT I
DID NOTICE THAT- THREE
INDIVIDUALS- CAME INTO THE
HEARING ROOM DID TO AND IF YOU
WISH TO GIVE PUBLIC COMMENT.
EVERYBODY'S SIGNALING NOW- SO
THAT BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
HEARING AND WE WILL RETURN A
WEEK. FROM NOW NEXT WEDNESDAY
THAT RIGHT. YEAH NEXT WEDNESDAY.
OKAY BECAUSE WE WILL IN FACT BE
BACK NEXT WEDNESDAY. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU ALL SPEND
A WE STAND ADJOURNED.